It is live right now.
We're doing it already.
I was watching the recording thing was flashing and I get again,
wasn't recording son of a bitch recording anybody could speak new stream thing.
You fuck you substitution for the expensive,
what is it that uh,
my buddy Justin used?
Yeah.
Tri caster.
That's supposed to be the shit.
Yeah,
they're awesome.
The Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by many things in which we love.
I,
one of them is audible.com.
Um,
audible.com is something that I have used for many,
many a moon.
Um,
and uh,
audible occasionally sponsors this podcast.
If you have never been to audible.com what audible.com is,
is it has a plethora of great like books on tape.
Um,
like people who like Steve Martin,
like read his book and it didn't he read his book on tape.
Yeah.
And he is one of the best ones that I,
I use audible a lot and that's one of my favorite books on tapes ever.
Yeah.
Um,
and there's,
there's so many of them,
so many great books there.
They also have the one book that I recommend to people on a regular basis,
which is the war of art for any creative people in creative types who are trying
to overcome procrastination or blocks or w you know what,
this Guy Steven Pressfield calls resistance.
It's a really brilliant,
brilliant book and it is available on tape as well.
I think that audible books are amazing,
um,
and even better,
then in my opinion than,
than regular books because what I use them for is when I'm stuck doing other
things that do that.
You know,
if you're on a plane,
you're essentially wasting time.
Unless I'm writing on a plane or unless I'm getting actual work done,
it's a fucking huge waste of time.
But what you can read a,
an awesome book on a plane and get like an educational experience,
get an enriching and exciting experience.
Um,
the commute,
same thing,
you know,
and with a beautiful,
beautiful thing about audible is,
you know,
you could download it to your iPod,
you can play it in your car,
you can play it at the gym.
It's a,
it's just an awesome service.
And if you go to audible.com Joe,
um,
I don't know what happens when you got over there.
It's probably better.
Check this out.
Here's a sample from,
oh,
you could try on but free for 30 days.
That's what happens.
You get a free audio book and you get to try audible free.
That is not really audible.com.
Other Steve Martin,
Steve Martin played his Banjo and he's just picking grow.
Let him pick.
Listen,
he'll,
he's a bad mother fucker.
Steve Martin,
one of the underrated comedians.
I did stand up comedy for 18 years.
10 of those years were spent learning.
Four years were spent refining,
yet that's his voice were spent in wild success.
My most persistent memory of that right here.
I'm going to get a boner and want to hear the whole time.
I know.
Yeah,
you need to get that.
I'm going to,
you know what?
I'm going to get that.
That gotten
me excited.
Just hearing him.
I fucking love people.
Even when I read that book comedy,
Brian It to me,
Oh,
it's great many years ago,
but hearing him talk about it,
it's better.
It's better than the book.
He talks about the ice house.
He started up here in the ice house,
the ice houses.
Fucking the bomb.
Diggity anyway,
go to bottled the audible.com forward slash Joe.
And what you get is,
uh,
you can try audible free for 30 days and you get a free audio book.
So check that shit out bitches.
And if you want to get a sexy tee shirt,
like the one I'm sporting here,
you've got to go to death squad.
Dot TV.
So desk squad.
Dot TV is where?
That's the original.
This is original.
This is the Oji kittycat tattooed on numerous people all throughout the land.
And Kevin [inaudible],
our friend is holding up.
That is the new one.
That was my favorite cat.
That creepy cat.
That cat creeps a fuck up.
I mean it's like,
it's like,
it's like playing spot in the copyright violation.
It's sure.
Well,
I'm not down with that,
but the cat is free.
It's a remix.
But the cat's not a remix.
That cat's dope as fuck.
Of course.
Anyway.
Thank you.
Everybody who came out to Toronto,
I saw the dust squad teachers.
I saw the higher primate tee shirts to the my tee shirt company.
I never even mentioned,
I'm the worst promoter ever from my own company.
Hire Dash [inaudible] dot com is my tee shirt company.
If you go there,
it's all tee shirts with monkeys and mushrooms.
It's monkeys and psychedelic drugs and um,
and I've got more common.
I've got some new ideas.
I'm retarded.
Okay.
There's something wrong with me.
Obviously.
I'm a grown man with children of my own.
I have a tee shirt company that's about monkeys and drugs.
Um,
we're out of a lot of shots sizes right now,
but we've got new shit coming in and they sell so quick that I don't talk about
this,
how lazy I am.
I don't talk about them because I don't want to have to replenish my supply and
call people and get work done.
Yeah.
But it's my,
it's,
this is my company a desk.
Squad.
Dot.
TV is Brian's company.
So you,
when you buy these things,
these are directly supporting us.
I also have a piece of onnit.com on a.com is the company that we've been working
with for years now.
Um,
and selling nutritional supplements.
And I tell everybody [inaudible] and that's another thing that I've had come up
to me on the road that is just humbling and amazing and inspiring.
How many people have come up to me and said they've lost a shitload of weight
since they started listening to this podcast.
They think about things differently that they're eating Kale shakes every day.
I'm a big proponent of nutrition.
There's a huge difference between the way I feel when I'm eating healthy and
when I feel when I'm not.
Your body needs a bunch of Shit to run good and sciences isolated.
The ones that affect your mind in a very positive way.
And these are called nootropics and what they essentially do is they help your
brain produce more human neurotransmitters,
makes your brain fire quicker,
and makes your brain you want.
You know,
the of days when you just feel fucking shitty.
We can't come up with names and you're,
you're scrambling.
You and your brain's like firing bad.
Just like the,
they're not coming out.
Even like a normal word.
Alpha brain prevents all that shit for me.
Uh,
it doesn't work for everybody if you're fucking smoking cigarettes and not
taking care of yourself.
I don't know how much it's going to affect you,
but it's like for me,
it has a big on an old 46
tower for me.
Yeah.
For me it has a big effect.
I've,
I fucking love this stuff.
I take it every day.
I also take shroom tech sport.
It's a quarter [inaudible] mushroom supplement that we sell,
which cordyceps mushroom has been showed to aid your,
your body's ability to process oxygen and it gives people more endurance.
It was sort of discovered by a high altitude herders.
They found that their cows were eating these mushrooms and they had more
activities so people started eating them.
And it's some crazy cryptic process where you have to grow this mold on the back
of a fucking caterpillar.
It's really,
yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
Like Google it or go to [inaudible] dot com all the questions to all the
important,
all the answers rather to the important questions that I'm sure you have if
you're smart,
which all these questions cannot be answered by a more on my,
by myself.
When I tell you all these things about like human neuro transmitters,
I don't really know what I'm saying.
I'm just sort of repeating.
You've read a pdf.
I've read exactly what it was.
Yeah,
I know what that says,
but I don't know.
Like really you can regurgitate paragraph three.
It sounds,
I can sound smart as fuck son,
but if you told me to spot,
you know like,
okay,
and the neurotransmitters do what exactly.
I'd be like,
well,
they'll make you fucking awesome.
I know that on a tee shirt with some monkeys.
Yeah.
I don't have any answers to those questions.
Uh,
we also sell kettle bells and battle ropes.
We have a hemp protein powder that we sell that is the very finest hemp protein
powder on earth.
It has raw cocoa in it and Maka and that need some of that.
It's fucking strong.
I'll have it sent to you need to let me know.
Look,
the the thing that we have,
the way we have it on it is that we're trying to sell you the very best shit
possible.
Everything we sell is the highest quality and it's not all cheap,
but it's the best you can get and for the nutritional supplements,
for the first 30 pills,
you get a 100% money back guarantee.
If you try off of brain,
you don't feel like it's doing anything for you,
you,
your money is refunded.
You'll need to have to return the product.
No one's trying to rip you off.
We are just only trying to sell you the things that I use,
the things that if you can afford them,
they are the very best ones available.
The kettlebells are there,
Troy kettle bells.
They're the very best kettlebells available.
Battle ropes,
the very best develop.
Most of it is the cheapest we can sell it.
The battle ropes are the cheapest you can find on the Internet.
The kettle bells are right up there.
There's literally as low as we can price them without losing money.
Selling them.
So this is all like super high end stuff and if you use a code name Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
That sounds like a real commercial.
It's so boring.
I want like you need an 80 style number how they used to sell action figures and
the 80s with kids busting through like foam brick walls and shit like that.
You need some like that for battle ropes,
ropes
and take you down with my battle real Jimmy and then ended,
there's a smoke machine that fires up.
We need like an old commercial like one of those atlas commercials where he was
on the beach and someone kicked sand in his face and he was like you mother
fucker.
And he picks up the ropes and you see his muscles.
Well when you think about the movements of battle ropes,
it's totally like chimpanzee movements.
When they're beating the shit out something or they were clubbing a bride is
dragged back to the case.
It's definitely primer.
It's good for hammer fist to boom.
Kevin Prayer has here you dirty bitches,
hold the fuck up kid.
Strap yourself in the launch.
I'm in the refractory period.
I need ice.
Oh Shit.
All Day.
All night.
All Day
controversy all over the world.
Kevin.
Mother fucking Perreira is here.
Bitches respect.
Ah,
so nice to see you again,
my friend.
Good to see you as well.
So you uh,
you will have a abandon your spot on television.
Like a real g stepped out into the real world,
man.
That takes balls the cord and slam through the get glass canopy.
For folks who don't know,
Kevin was the host of a attack of the show on g four for it.
Jesus.
How many years?
God,
God is with the network for 10 years.
And I hosted attack,
uh,
for six.
When did I first do your show?
What year was it?
We were probably two or three years into it.
So 2007 or something like give or take seven or eight.
Yeah,
it was.
And we've been friends ever since.
And Kevin's on the podcast stuff several times.
We went to things remembered after the first show and we got one of those little
heartbreak necklaces.
Mine has bee on it and Fri and you have the other letters and sounds together we
summon a very sexual captain planet.
Make Brian Jealous Right now.
Brian.
Brian has the Arrow that goes through the heart right to the knee.
Write anything into three ways.
The mail in which one's the females,
the male,
the Arrow that goes to the heart.
You know when the circle nose,
those two circles at the bottom to represent testicles or really it should.
I should
write your own Google.
I'm fucking the wicked.
He sure I got the answers to this bitch.
Yeah,
man,
totally should.
Right.
It should look like a dick.
Why?
Why does it have to be like why didn't show the symbol for mail and assign those
things?
It was probably someone who really couldn't draw that well.
So we set out,
here's a stick with a loop and now we call it the mail it.
But it was a dude who designed princess thing when he stopped being a person.
See,
same company.
I think that was illegal thing though.
I think that was one of those record companies fucking you over things.
Well,
I'll tell you what.
If you just have a symbol,
your music is fucking hard to torrent.
Yeah.
If you're just like alt j uses a triangle and thankfully you can type in all j,
but if you try to just try it,
if you just have to type the triangle that requires extended ASCII knowledge.
My Dad's not going to pirate that album.
Wait Yard.
Yeah.
How would you draw?
That's that prince symbol.
You would have to get a font made up and then someone would have to agree to
assign a key to that font and the op.
The [inaudible] would have to be changed.
Right?
I O s 6.5 that we'll have the Emoji and prince icon set.
Don't think it's necessary.
I think he's Prince again.
What do you think contra to went over that I think is,
what are you doing over there?
The old street,
serious money.
I went on to the old reports show.
That was wild.
[inaudible] was awesome,
man.
I used to love that show.
My wife would get so mad at me for watching that stupid show.
Which one did you watch?
Screen savers or cry help like screensavers
this is so boring.
Well,
that was the thing,
like it was a whole,
I've loved it.
I was a super fan of Tech TV and Leo's and everything they did,
but it's wild.
The notion that on television where they're trying to reach a very broad
audience,
there was an hour or sometimes five hour marathon long show of like you got a
problem with your printer driver.
Okay,
what model HPD you have?
All right,
let's check some dll files scrolling.
I'm like,
what?
Talk about narrow casting.
There's been 30 minutes helping one person with their fucking printer drivers
and I loved it.
It was awesome.
I learned so much.
I think we,
I think we underestimate people's attention spans for these type of things.
I really do.
I think people are very curious about those kind of,
and some folks are,
look,
there was a UFC this weekend or these guys fought that for the flyweight title
and it's a fucking amazing fight between Joseph Benevidez and this guy,
Demetrius money mouse Johnson who won when and decision and the crowd was
booing.
They were booing because nothing they,
these guys were fucking throwing down.
I mean it was a want to see the big power shots and that they want to see
someone getting knocked unconscious.
It was,
it was so gross.
It was just so,
such a plethora of dummies.
It was so hard.
So it's like you're never going to get away from that.
Well not always going to have a certain percentage.
People are,
you can train people
to have certain viewing habits and expectations and that's what like the Google
Youtube channels that came out.
Some people are doing 30 40 minute long shows on youtube that are actually doing
pretty well.
And that kind of behavior a year ago was unheard of.
The notion that someone would stare at this to stream video for an hour or half
hour to watch a web show was unheard of.
So people can be trained to have different expectations of running times in
length.
So you can,
you can manipulate attention
spans essentially.
You can,
it can be done.
Yes.
Well sir,
I don't think it's really manipulating attention spans.
I think we're underestimating people's interests in things.
When we started doing the podcast,
everybody told Brian and I that we had to shorten it.
Yeah,
couldn't agree more.
You have these long ass conversation remind you got short hair.
I stood up and I was like,
there's no way I go.
I don't get it.
Just a conversation.
If you don't like it,
you shut it off.
If you don't have any more time left to shut it off.
Like there's no obligation to continue with this conversation.
But I want,
I like conversations that I have with my friends when we're,
we're up for a couple hours smoking pot or something like that and we have these
really intense moments where you know,
I'm being aided by his intellect and he's introducing thoughts.
To my mind,
this is a real like regeneration and refreshing of the mind when you have these
kind of conversations.
You know,
even if you're just talking stone shit about simulation theory and and you know,
and whether or not mushrooms really are a portal to another dimension.
Just stupid shit.
The shit that comes out at hour two and a half around that mark is when you get
there,
which is why you'll never see those kind of conversations on a late night talk
show where you have three and a half minutes plug your movie,
you get to the clip,
get out and go.
People don't realize the fun and just shooting the shit with cool people and
that's when you,
when someone said that
there were too long,
I'm like,
you're crazy.
But you could say just because everybody else is doing an hour doesn't mean it
has to be an hour.
That's nuts.
Giving them too much is way better than not giving them enough like the I,
the idea is to just put out the best shit you could put out and if you could
keep going for after two hours,
why wouldn't you keep going?
I could see this is what you're trying to do,
right?
You're trying to try to tune people into this real conversation.
It's kind of one of the reasons that I actually ended up having to leave attack.
I mean,
there were a myriad reasons,
but one of those things was I was getting a chance to meet so many fascinating
people who I was passionate about and wanted to talk with and I was given four
minutes live with them and it's my first time saying,
hello,
you need a podcast in the works,
the works in the world.
Dude,
you need to do on tonight.
Right after this podcast,
I'll be your first guest on your pod.
This isn't me tugging off strangers.
This is me spinning plates.
All right,
I got,
I know a couple in the error,
I'm sure,
but what I'm saying is your gift is that you're an intelligent,
curious guy and when one of your gifts,
obviously we're brilliant.
Talk about my eyes.
I love your face too.
You have great bone structure.
Apple.
I'm not man.
I'm saying that there's lost.
I'm lost already.
I was lost before I got here.
There's,
there's no better expression for or portal for expression for you then a than an
a podcast where you can control,
especially something like this where you can add video,
essentially do whatever we want.
It's so close to a real television show except it's not.
There's no ads ever.
And those ads in the beginning and then the whole fucking thing runs for three
hours.
Yes.
People still complain.
You pretty much do that already though.
You did stick cam last night for an hour.
You randomly,
I'll hop on and like if I'm going to drum,
I'll live casts some of my,
my drumming,
but then it always ends up with meat,
sweaty and having an emotional outpour and then the strangers.
Oh,
I did.
I will press the hand up against the Webcam.
It looks like it is a Portuguese hedgehog.
Just mashed against the Lens.
This girls right now going through your recorded youtube Ustream and there's
videos trying to find it primarily 18 to 34 year old males going through that
youth street trying to find it.
You more of like a gay crush?
Yeah,
I'm,
why am I a twink or a bear?
How does that work?
I think you just probably have assembled like coffee,
like this handsome young guys.
It looks like you could be easily overpowered.
Hmm.
That's what it is.
Sexual,
I wouldn't even fight.
I would scrap if that turns you on.
That's about it.
I parked your face and I thought it would make you harder,
but just that that alone,
that sentence is really disturbing.
I might fight if it makes you,
Brian and I were having a conversation before we went live of like girls that
request and demand that you strike them during the act and I've been with one
and it was insane and I couldn't,
I couldn't do it more than more than five or 10 sessions.
Yeah.
I've never had a girl asking me to hit her,
but I have had girls ask me to rape them.
That's even worse.
That's kind of,
yeah,
like I've had girls me off.
Oh,
they want you to look like she explained it to me that she wanted,
she wanted me to rape her and she wanted to me off and I was like,
I feel
like that sentence,
it's followed with your honor.
She was asking for it.
We were in an alley.
Let me break my nails.
It gets the concrete never wound up doing right.
I should just clarify.
I just thought it was the craziest thing I'd ever heard in my life.
I don't know.
It's like,
look,
I'm,
I'm into living with reality.
I don't know what you're trying to,
I'm not barely,
you know,
we don't have been dating a little while.
We didn't need any fantasies yet.
Like Jesus fucking Christ.
Like how about a regular sex life is going stale.
How about a rape fantasy?
You really are who I really am.
Both horny thrown into a van and hit me with a two by four and then stream it.
No.
So she wanted to fight me off.
It was this weird thing.
She's like,
but you know that it's not so,
it's okay.
I go,
it's not because it's still,
I'm still gonna do it.
Like in,
you know,
I don't want to do that.
It's just,
I don't,
I don't want to associate like physical aggression with sexuality.
It's just,
it's tough because this isn't my story to really tell.
And I have a very close knit group of friends,
but someone in that group whose name rhymes with mom,
no,
no.
What's his name?
Come on,
give up.
Here's the thing.
No,
no,
no.
This is,
it's a brilliant story.
He started dating and it give them a fake name in a cliff notes this year.
Okay.
My Buddy Dale Dale started to date a woman Shariece Shariece told Dale it was
always a fantasy,
is fantasy of hers to be raped.
But it's sort of one of those things where you can't ask to be raped because
then you know,
and it would ruin the fantasy.
You just always want it.
So after they'd been dating for no less than a year,
and they were both into kinky sex and weird sex circles and kind of went around
in those Kevin Roads.
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna say yes,
but I'm going to tap my nose and wink can point your way.
So my buddy Kevin was like,
oh my God,
tea kettle bells.
So
less than a year they'd been dating.
He arranges,
she's flying in from town.
He,
he arranges for three giant dudes to pick her up at the airport,
take her away,
throw rent a van,
pretty much run a train on her outside of gas station.
She's crying,
thinks the real thing has happened.
Then he shows up and uh,
he says happy birthday and she cried and thanked him and couldn't believe it.
There's still the to this day.
Wow.
Yup.
That's the first time I met Kevin Rose.
I was invited to run a train on his girlfriend.
Whoa.
I had no idea.
Sara Lane.
And you were still dating house?
Absolutely not.
Absolutely not him whatsoever.
That is the namesake.
Why does it show up for tests?
This is all just a joke.
No one.
But that's a crazy story,
man.
That's one up story.
And she liked it.
She liked,
and so that's when I go like immediately I go,
well,
you know what?
I want to be clear as well.
That's not for me.
Not necessarily for me.
All right.
I have a rape fantasy and I would love for three dudes to run a train on me.
Sure.
I get that right.
So not for me,
but on the other hand,
on the flip side of that coin,
that's fucking love.
Like at some point you go,
what were the odds of those two ships passing in the night?
One,
having a rape fantasy,
the other be willing to fulfill
it in that capacity and go for it and then say happy birthday and say happy
birthday.
That might be the craziest story.
The cake is on your face.
Craziest story I've ever heard about a man and a woman together.
Pretty fantastic.
People's trying to think of it is that they could see Adam's get to know this
isn't,
this isn't,
this is nobody that it's in any sort of limelight.
They don't have Wikipedia.
It's really fucked up that some,
you know that there's these variables because it would be nice if rape was
always bad.
You know,
it would be nice if girls did not ever have a rape fantasy,
so there couldn't be any weirdness.
I can't remember which comedian is,
I might've been Louis C K that had a bit about when a girl says no and she's
like,
why didn't you go for it?
Cause you said no.
Yeah,
but it meant no playfully.
It's like I'm not going to have sex with you on the off chance that you're into
that.
You know what I mean?
There's no,
no should really mean no and yes can problem is.
That's not what she wants.
She really wants you to take it,
which is crazy because for a woman who doesn't want that,
it's a horrific idea.
I always,
I always apologize after and I have a hump.
They hallmark needs to make cards for that.
Like,
sorry,
you didn't want to be forcibly sext.
Yeah.
This girl,
this girl call an Uber for you dated that wanted me to rape her.
She got over it.
She only asked for it once,
but it was really weird.
Was that rooted in something else?
I don't see a victim of a sex crime earlier.
I was like,
no.
She is like,
she likes super aggression.
She liked aggression,
like she just battle rope movements on your face and bash.
You wanted some fucking drunk.
She was just a wild pitch.
I don't know.
I don't know what I'll have her contact.
No,
this was many minutes on Facebook.
I don't think you can find if I battle rope.
Thank you.
Should not.
She might ruined.
I was so tiny.
I would snap in half at the thought.
Plus,
she's got to be like 40 now so it's over that.
So I don't mind.
I don't mind when the tread on the tires is worn off.
I'll hop in there.
The rim,
it depends when you say it's over,
but I saw Cindy Crawford who was like almost 50 or she might be 50 and she is
still so hot as fuck.
What about Gwen's Tiffani?
Isn't she like 40 something now and I don't know.
I just saw in the at the airport on the cover of some magazine and I'm like,
I would absolutely toss it and they're not going to ever have a chance.
But say that though,
based on a magazine cover,
cause that might as well be like a werewolf.
I get,
I get that there's,
there's Photoshop and camera trickery and get at that goes on.
You seen those photos of Madonna,
Riesling,
a skeletor.
Yeah.
But then you see her in other promotional pictures and she looks hot still.
It's like,
what's going on?
Who's lying to me?
Someone's lying boners confused.
I'm fucking really creeped out by this.
Like that.
There must be a phantom of the opera.
Would you,
would you bang Madonna knowing fuck really looks like not even born.
I'm not into that story of it and none of that.
I get a tagger ear and monitor.
When I was 17 I was in love with her really big thing for her.
You loved her music.
I love that movie.
Um,
the,
the fission Mitosis,
vision quest,
she played a,
she sang a song and vision quest and it was like,
she had a couple songs on the soundtrack and the soundtrack was what I would
use to train with.
I would always train to the vision quest soundtrack.
I had a Walkman cassette Walkman dude,
old school and when I would do my sprints I would listen to that.
So I had this like weird crush on her because of that.
So awkwardly fast forward the cassette to get to the crescendo of the song
before a sprint.
No,
I wasn't.
So I want to believe you.
It was difficult back then because back then it was like,
it was,
it was like this is not so easy.
Yeah.
You rarely didn't queue things up.
I would cue up the beginning of the song right before a sprint.
Maybe you did go through,
but it's suck because of the fucking cassette thing was too big.
So it's slapping against your other hard plastic slapped against you.
That's how fetishes are born.
I was in a Madonna back then,
which is really funny because I was 17 and then I found out she was 26 I was
like,
damn that bitch,
it's old.
That's all.
I'm 45 now.
I'm fucking practically dead.
That's ridiculous.
We don't want to feel great,
but uh,
I've just never been into the Madonna type.
I never been into like super aggressive business and they took a flex break.
You're not going to put a podcast on hold and then he's going to hit it.
Right?
I'd fuck me.
Anybody else?
Let me raped me.
Joe,
take me out behind the name.
Come on.
I won't bear Macy.
I promise.
Flexing.
I broke loose and eyelash and a felony level.
Oh,
I hate that.
She will.
I will go ahead and put a key between my fingers,
but I'm not going to jab you with it.
Just come and take me.
What a shitty design our eyes are that occasionally the rafters fall off into it
and then you can't see like what if a fucking a bear was trying to get you an
eyelash felony awry like mother Fucker,
hold on,
hold on.
We're going to devolve very soon.
We're going to be become so reliant on plastic chips in our bodies and
technology to regulate us at.
The body's just going to stop.
They're like,
we don't really need eyes anymore.
We'll figure that out with thermal.
I disagree.
I think it,
I think it's going to be augmented in assimilation course.
Yeah.
We're still going to have some sort of a reading type thing going on.
Look,
eventually we are going to be those gray aliens.
There's no way around it.
If you look,
it'll be [inaudible] drives.
We were at the Santa Barbara Zoo the other day and got to check some gorillas
out.
Oh,
it's fucking beautiful.
Santa Barbara is amazing zoo there.
I've been going there with my family.
I love,
I love Santa Barbara.
It's a gorgeous community.
It's,
it's amazing.
Nice little restaurants,
beautiful neighborhoods.
Beautiful view that the weather's amazing and they got this cool zoo,
but all zoos bummed me out.
If I didn't have children,
I would never go to the zoo because I hate the idea of,
I don't mind the idea of hunting.
I think the hunting is the way people were supposed to live,
but depends on how you're hunting as well.
If you're paying for 5,000 birds to be released so you can shoot a gun.
Yeah,
not really hunting asshole.
That was,
that's a weird thing they do with old rich dudes.
They just give them a shirt,
bang or bring you out in a range rover and put you within three meters of an
elephant in hand.
You a rifle and he's pointed anywhere in his general direction and pull the
trigger and I'll get a of you with a foot on it.
That's not hunting.
Not necessarily what I mean,
but what a,
I get what you're saying is,
yeah,
what bums me out is animal person,
animal prisons bum me out.
Way more than hunting because at least if you're hunting an animal,
even if you're not going to eat that animal,
if you're going to just give that animal away,
which is kind of weird.
Like this Guy Matt Hughes,
a UFC champion,
just got in trouble with a lot of people.
People are angry at him because he went to South Africa and shot everything.
She did one of those things including women and children,
Zebra and a bunch of different animals and,
but even that,
to me it's like that still seems to be better than the fucking zoo.
I think the zoo is one of the,
like the,
the the,
if you want to talk about cruelty to animals,
the zoo is one of the most fucked up places on earth because those animals are
denied all of their natural activities.
All of them.
We think that just because they have food there,
okay,
that is madness.
Or Hey,
well,
you know what?
Their forest was getting cut down,
so at least we saved them.
And I'm like,
is that really saving them,
putting,
putting a natural animal that has instincts that are predatory and then dangling
meat from a poll for it or having it pace and a four by four cell and they don't
even fucking get Wifi.
They don't even have wifi.
They don't have anything to kill even a hot,
you know,
and that's,
that's something that they do do in other countries,
like in other countries,
especially in Asia,
when they have tiger preserves,
they preserve these tigers,
but they feed them live goats.
Right.
Have you ever seen that Brian throwing throw a few of those up because there's
hundreds of them online I've seen preserves where they feed them.
Like they fed the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park,
which is a goat on a chain,
which better than just handing it the meat that's already killed.
But at some point you got to let,
you should let them go.
Go.
You should let them actually hunt and [inaudible] and you know,
go through those animalistic behavior.
Yeah,
that would be better if you had like an ecosystem in a place.
But even that you shouldn't contain it.
It shouldn't be that this tiger has no idea what happens if he walks 20 miles to
the ocean.
It shouldn't be that the tiger should be able to go wherever the fuck the tiger
is,
if that's his habitat,
unless we choose to make them extinct.
If we choose it too fucking dangerous,
they're eating too many people and we gotta start jacking him,
which by the way,
if I lived in India,
I'd be hunting tigers every fucking day of the week.
More people have died from tigers in India than anywhere in the world.
They had like just the Sunderbans alone is at somewhere like 300,000 people have
been murdered by tigers over the last hundred years and that's because they're
building in their habitat or because they're trying to keep them as pets because
poor people are living near a monster.
I mean,
it's a crime.
Not only that,
there's bands is a a,
it's a brackish ocean and apparently they have a,
the tigers drink this water and the water is extra salty,
so it makes some really aggressive.
It makes him irritated all the time and they're really me.
Yeah.
I had a bit about it in my act.
A true story about these poor fucking fishermen.
They were in a boat.
There was like five guys in a boat and this tiger swam out to the boat,
jumped in,
killed the guy,
dragged him through the water to the shore,
dropped his body off of the shore,
jumped back in the water,
go get the other guys and did it again.
Did it three times.
He did it three times,
so the last two guys were just fucking
fucking start paddling,
dude.
You got to figure something out.
You know what's happening?
Who Knew Tigers with that fucking evil like they are really are monsters because
then they're not doing it for food.
They're doing it because they can like at that point Tomic how?
How could you just,
I want to swipe off a years and make a necklace.
They are doing it for the sport.
How could you justify keeping that thing around?
What does this a bowl?
This is a goat feeding from a,
that's a cow.
I guess it looks like.
There it is.
Yeah,
the cow.
Fuck.
Oh,
there we go.
Right over to his.
John's like you rushed him a little bit like too is talking shit.
Yeah,
I'll spear this motherfucker.
I like how they go Jujitsu style.
They go right to the bottom and then we'll call this call.
It's like,
okay,
he's got site control and he's got the neck.
As long as he's got the knack,
he's good.
He's got the top of the spine now.
This is really hard for the cow to get anything done here.
He's at least the cow standing though.
The key.
The cows got to figure out some way to go to his back and kick that thing off
and then get back to his feet and run away,
but it doesn't look good.
The Tiger's got the back of the neck.
I think he's fucked.
Don't forget to check out a new season of the ultimate fighter.
There's a dead cow.
I don't get it.
Oh,
there's a live cow.
they have a long time.
Shit.
Yeah.
Look how they bring them out.
That poor cow before they let him get killed by a lion.
He gets a few with shit dragged by a golf cart.
He gets fucking ball gagged and strung up by his hooves and that's,
that's exactly what they did to him.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Zoo.
But so Santa Barbara Zoo was exciting for you?
It was good or it was,
it was sad.
Just sad.
It's cool because the kids get to see the,
the,
the fucking animal jail.
But it's sad when you see,
you explain to them like,
Hey,
this is not natural for these animals.
I mean,
or you know,
you just let it sit for and to,
you know,
so it's just like,
this is,
no,
I'm not being upset.
I'm just being very passionate.
I'm just saying when I explained to them,
it's just like I get,
I just want them to repeat the names and know where it lives and what it's,
what it does.
And then eventually we'll get to purpose though.
That's an really,
I would rather show them DVDs.
I really would.
But you know,
kids like looking at Shit,
you know,
they,
I can never get my daughter sit down and watch like a documentary on the Congo
or something like that.
But if you take him somewhere and show them some actual real shit,
you know,
that's,
that has a different impact on them.
But what my point was while standing there looking at the gorillas,
I was looking at a gorilla and looking at me and then thinking about gray
aliens.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's next.
It has to be.
That really is us.
Like I think those fucking eyes,
it's because they have like builtin sunglasses because we've completely fucked
the environment.
You can't see anymore.
You go outside active layers and reflective coatings.
They have those big fucking totally black eyes that shits his sunglasses,
builtin sunglasses or Oakleys and 40 20 to our eyes got way bigger after Google
goggles.
It's like an unexpected turn.
Well,
Google goggles,
not only does it give you cancer of the brain,
but that cancer specifically makes your eyes grow.
That changed evolution.
So that's what happened.
The human eye because of the large almond sized or shaped.
So when that happened,
and then eventually we went with pure telekinesis,
people stopped talking to mouth shrunk up.
We won't need physical vessels once.
Once we can figure out how to digitize the consciousness,
especially if the physical physical vessel is going to be universal.
Indiscernible like it looks like the gray aliens are the gray aliens.
It's not like you see like a Shaquille O'Neal gray alien right next to the image
racist.
You're saying they all look the same and I see completely different
personalities.
I can pick out Doug from Zana do.
All right.
Okay.
Have you ever had any sort of an experience with anything that you thought was
paranormal,
whether it was a ghost?
Yeah,
I mean on Salvia,
I've,
I've experienced the universe as a pixel of a human being.
I've absolutely seen it and felt it and understood it,
but sober,
I haven't felt like phantoms are cold chills or word sobers a very interesting
word because I agree.
You know,
I agree with the idea to a certain extent that when you're,
when you're intoxicated that that is an impaired state and that what you're
saying is probably not real.
It's just a distortion of all your,
you know,
your,
your sort of,
your sensory perceptions and the,
you know,
your body reacting to poison and you can trick your body into synesthesia where
however,
there's times when I'm high or I completely disagree that it's not that you
wouldn't eat it.
It's not an,
it's not an impaired state.
It's an enhanced state.
It's very difficult to manage,
enhance state and there's a lot going on but it's not impaired.
It's modified,
it's modified,
modified.
It's,
it makes reality a little slippery.
You can get socially awkward,
you can get paranoid.
There's a lot of things that can happen that what it is is you have a massive
amount of extra sensitivity and it's almost the exact opposite of being drunk
and what people don't understand.
It's like,
oh,
he's impaired.
He's on the pot when I'm on the pot.
Okay.
I'm like,
I play pool twice as good,
maybe three times as good.
I can play like professional level for long stretches of time when I'm high as
fuck my cow,
I write better comedy.
Like there's a lot going on that you can't say is,
is a,
there's no downside of that.
There's no,
it's not a detrimental situation.
And Carl Sagan has said something that I,
it's,
uh,
my quote on my message board and when he said it,
I was like,
thank you.
It says,
I am convinced that there are genuine and valid levels of perception available
with cannabis and probably with other drugs,
which are through the defects of our society and our educational system
unavailable to us without such drugs.
And those are those,
there's real like clarity in,
in some of these experiences.
It's just so much recreational use is so much fucking around with all of us that
it's been,
especially with people who don't do any of these things,
they don't smoke pot.
They've never done mushrooms.
That it seems like a recreational,
silly type activity.
It doesn't seem like there's any validity.
Well,
they're,
yeah,
they're still,
and they're still banking off of the,
uh,
the stories and the connotations that have been handed down since the reefer
madness days from grandpa told someone's parents that,
that referral make you silly.
It'll make you crazy and make you a,
you know,
a Druggie,
you'll be a no nothing and then that just gets handed down and handed down.
It would be really cute.
We would be a cute fun thing to watch bumble into walls if it wasn't for all the
violence.
If it wasn't for like the shit that's going down today in Spain.
Have you seen the ship Brian and just seeing the video,
please pull up the video of the Spain protesting because it is crazy.
Yeah.
The [inaudible] news.
Fuck you CNN.
Fuck you.
Fox News.
You guys suck.
You are fucking frauds.
They are not the news cogs in the machine.
The owned by corporations to to,
to facilitate an agenda.
It's propaganda.
Keyless.
The fact that no one's covering what's going on in Bahrain,
no one is covering.
I mean there's the amount of coverage in America on this Spain thing is shameful
and their depiction of it is shamefully inaccurate.
That it's just a small protest and it's,
no,
this is a fucking whole civilization rising up against their leaders.
I mean people are looting for food and trash bins.
That's how dire the situation has got for a large section of that population and
now they're taking to the streets and nobody knows about it and the the,
the actual reported figures of unemployment or at 25% but those are disputed by
the population that they say that it could be even worse than that.
The reported numbers of,
um,
and by the way,
those figures,
they only count those who are actively seeking employment and are unable to find
it.
Which means if 25% is statistically unemployed,
there might be another 25% that it's fucking given up your exactly resorting to
trash cans and now looting.
Yeah,
you're exactly right.
That's the people that are still in the system that are being counted as
unemployed and people use that as an example of our society because our society,
we try to keep it unemployment's down.
It's up.
How you don't,
you don't know shit.
You don't know shit.
Absolutely.
Do you know about people that are in your system?
That's it.
There's a huge amount of people out there that have fucking thrown in the towel
and it's,
that's what's going on in Spain.
It's,
if you see,
look at the videos,
it's fucking notice the badge in the corner.
Not Cnn,
not MSNBC,
not fox,
nothing.
It's,
you know,
it's,
we've done such a terrible job.
What is our t stand for again?
It's not Reuters,
it's a God.
I watch other stuff and all the time piece with a fucking hell.
A little button while they're taking pictures of them.
This is crazy.
But what's really crazy is he's fucking cops,
man.
Like they,
they are just employees of the machine.
They're not even the machine.
They're regular folks.
Yup.
The regular folks are attacking regular for these people.
These people are fighting for their jobs right now,
just as the people riding are trying to fight for jobs.
And that's what's so sad is that this is how disconnected it is.
They have to lay down their arms.
It has to get worse.
It has to get worse to the point where the cops realize,
okay,
we are the civilization.
We are this.
They are clubbing.
Oh look at that guy kick roundhouse kick to the body.
Very weak roundhouse kick.
No,
no turn of the hips at all.
Look,
people are kicking them and pushing them down.
That's fucking crazy man.
That cops,
nobody took his back.
Someone should have taken his back.
Yeah,
well they're going to busy.
Sounds like you got to get over under soon.
They'll bring out the sonic weaponry and the and the drones and the UAE fees and
that.
I mean,
that's why this kind of descent doesn't happen in the states right now because
we have,
uh,
we have a military that's a police force that will roll out not only that,
vehicles on rifles,
we have new laws protecting the clients.
Just in case this shit goes down where they legally can do a bunch of shit that
they would never allow it to do.
Just a couple of years.
They can pull you off the streets and detain you before anything ever happens
because you might be a thought leader.
And you know,
it's really disturbing to me.
All these celebrities and all these different people who are,
are standing up for Obama and campaigning for Obama.
And even like guys that I respect and intelligent people are saying and keys
better than Mitt Romney.
Like it's what,
what did you,
what are you looking at?
I'm like,
You are you,
are you paying attention to what this guy is doing to the constitution?
They're cherry picking a few moral issues,
which is always what it boils down to,
which is sad.
Uh,
you know,
I happen to agree with the moral stance of Obama versus Romney a little bit
more,
but it doesn't fucking matter what aspect of his civil unions.
Gay Rights.
That's a big one.
You know what that is?
That's a democratic talking point.
Sure.
You know,
he,
he is,
cause they won't talk about money in politics,
which is the root of 90% of all the fucking issues we have right now.
And nobody's going to talk about it cause it's what lining their pockets.
Yeah.
When you,
when it comes to something that's actually important that he is not standing up
for us.
Nope.
When it comes for it,
they're going to rate the dispensaries here in la despite saying that's not
going to happen.
What they just did,
they just closed in on 71 of them.
Yeah.
Well they sent,
they sent notices to a bunch and they're suing to,
they haven't started shattering glass yet,
but believe me,
that's two weeks away.
Yeah.
The whole thing is really sick and this is supposed to be this awesome
presidents regime.
I mean,
he's running things right now.
Who's running things right now while he's running a campaign is
fucking doing this.
Should it be nonprofit?
Shut up.
You're telling me that the DEA that has nothing better to do for real then go
after pot companies.
That is one of the weakest ways to get a color.
By the way,
700 dispensary's can't be opened and operated and less.
There's fucking demand for 700 dispensary's.
How about the [inaudible] is a law that says you're allowed to have it here and
to pretend that it's worse than anything else,
that you've already got legal and this is a reason why you're going after it.
It's crazy.
Obama.
That's why I'm always against the medicinal marijuana argument because it
ignores the recreational argument,
which is just as fucking valid as the medicinal one certainly is,
but the medicinal one,
I think while in a world of madness,
there's a lot of people,
not me as necessarily
I could get by without it.
They're,
the reasons that I use it for is not nothing's terminal.
There's people who have terminal illnesses,
illnesses.
There's people who have cancer and marijuana is the only thing that gives them
an appetite,
like there's nothing else that works as good people that will have seizures if
they do not smoke pot,
and yet someone is pulling the joint out of their hand and saying,
no,
you need to have a seizure because a,
this needs to be illegal.
That's why when whenever anybody talks about the human body and they're,
they're doing it from an ideological standpoint without any real medical
training or even reading research,
you're talking to any your ass like when you got to be an asshole,
like rush limbo that's talking about some girl wanting to be a slut so she can
get a birth control.
Would that asshole doesn't understand is that some women get ovarian cysts if
they don't take birth control.
They have medical issues.
There's a lot of them that women can use birth control with and it cleans them
up.
Sorry,
Joe.
He's just popped a handful of oxycontin and chased it with alcohol so he can't
hear you right now because let's not forget he was chastising people who wanted
to smoke pot while taking handfuls of pharmaceuticals.
Well,
not only that,
he was doing it illegally.
He was having his made go out and buy his,
uh,
he's oxies forum.
They said,
we,
we researched it,
we researched it on Wikipedia and it said that he was up to 30 a day according
to his made decided by Johnny balls.
17.
He's the one who put that sentence in there.
He is the most trusted source on the Wikipedia cut to the Johnny Ball 17 Twitter
account.
Johnny was just open.
There's a scramble for it right now.
I hope there is.
Yeah.
It's insane.
When I think about unemployment and I think about an eye,
this may transition into a TSA rant and I apologize if it does cause it's still
fresh.
Yeah,
well we got to talk about that.
Anyway,
the biggest fucking government works program that's really going on right now.
Our tax dollars going to create a system to create jobs to demean us and make us
feel like criminals from wanting to take a flight,
a program that is inefficient,
ineffectual by thousands of not thousands.
That's hyperbole by hundreds of sorted papers that is inefficient,
ineffective fuel that demeans us.
That leads to a lobbyists in government kickbacks for these corporations that
make machines that scan us and take nude photos.
It's essentially are the folks that do it for the folks that do the Tsa,
it is a shit job.
Yeah.
You're dealing with people that don't want to be there.
Absolutely.
Dealing with people that don't want to comply and in their defense.
Look,
there's that fucking classic Stanford study that we brought up over and over
again of what happened when they just had college students have one person in
charge or the board.
The other person is,
yeah,
the prisoner.
When they,
when you do that,
people abuse people.
People were supposed to be equal folks.
That's just the way it is.
It's not,
there's not supposed to be cops for the,
isn't there a law?
Isn't there a law against uniforms for,
for people that aren't law enforcement officials having uh,
like markings or patterns are then how do you work at Burger King?
But no,
no,
no.
Well,
because you're not,
you're not wearing a badge and you're not wearing patches.
You are a few of the manager.
You have a sheriff's a 10 share of bad.
It's,
I believe the Colonel Sanders about stripes doesn't cross it.
I'm the of this grill.
Well
you should like,
but they're not,
they're not actually by the way.
They're not cops.
They are.
They are regular folks that are wearing 10 badges and patches and I've met a lot
of fans there but that's different that the cops are here,
port police and they are police officers and they come in when the shit actually
gets mailed to mace you and Frisk you.
I've never had a problem at the,
at the TSA ever with people being rude to me with people.
I've never had that problem.
But do you go through the machines?
I go through the machines and I'm friendly.
I'm friendly,
I'm friendly shit,
but I opt out.
Brendan Walsh said that he had a problem with the same thing.
He opted out on the way to Toronto.
What I've heard is that this radiation in those machines,
they have a really registered it yet,
but if you really want to worry about radiation you shouldn't be showing on the
first place because the flight itself is incredibly re Radiohead radiation.
It to me is is a moot point.
Like yeah,
I don't think I deserve it.
It's a violation.
It's a rights violation plus the rapid scan corporation,
which is one of the two big corporations that had like,
you know,
the $70 million contracts to install these machines.
They were funding Chertoff who was the ex head of the Homeland Security
Administration.
Like they've increased their lobbying five,
five,
uh,
by,
by like 50% or something since 2008,
2010.
That was the last study I read.
So Lord knows how much money they're spending now to kick.
They get kickbacks to people in power to do these no bid contracts to put in
these machines,
which by the way,
most most security and defense experts tell you that they can't actually detect
the plastic explosives that could blow up at seven 47.
Like they can't actually detect it.
Plus there was a case in Florida just not only like probably two years ago where
hundreds of thousands of the photos from people going through those machines
because it does store photos,
even though it doesn't display him.
Those photos were hacked and it was.
They said,
we don't store these photos,
they don't get taken,
but they have a nude picture of you somewhere,
Lord.
No Lord knows how that's going to come back to haunt you.
So the radiation is to me a moot point.
I look good naked dude.
I want to see at least the house there's going to be at Tsa Fetish Porn.
Absolutely going to be fetish,
say people release the hounds.
It's just absurd to me that my tax dollars go towards buying these machines for
these corrupt corporations to have them installed to make me feel like a
criminal,
to snap a photo of me naked,
which don't make me any safer as I go onto a flight.
You think it doesn't make you any safer?
Don't you think that the people could take guns on planes?
They would if it was no metal detection,
you would have to deal with the same sort of instances of people being crazy in
society on a plane as you would on the ground.
I think metal detectors are good.
I do.
I think the idea of checking your bags is good.
There's too many cons.
There are certainly,
there are certainly there should be a standard of protection.
You know,
metal detector.
Do you want to scan the baggage of that's fine,
but I think we've drawn the line way too far and we've drawn it to a point now
where if an like,
first of all,
we've always been one step behind.
Let's not forget nine 11 happened with box cutters.
All right?
There was no explosives that were no bombs.
There were no guns.
It was Fox messy official story and Info wars.com
we know if the government inside job bin Ladin to a determined to attack.
We've got the documents,
ladies and gentlemen,
there is no way you can take over a plane with a box cutter.
Look at this article by Johnny Balls.
17 he has done the math.
It checks out.
If you going to infowars.com and buy gold and a crank flashlight and the crank
fleshlight Anita a crank fleshlight slash radio fuck your way to freedom.
Yeah.
I believe the official story,
the most fantastical stories,
by the way,
those flashlights need a rechargeable battery on them so they can heat up.
Yeah.
I should be able to press a button and have it get one,
but we don't use them anymore,
so I don't be,
don't fuck you mean you don't fall apart.
You don't talk about them.
And if you don't do it anymore,
do you still fuck them though?
Uh,
there's
not one good sponsor,
but it's,
I think it got to a point where we probably saturated their market and quite
honestly,
we made more money from other people.
Um,
yeah,
we're always one step behind.
So here's what,
here's what concerns me is that now we're at a point where let's say they take
away the rapid scan machines,
right?
Or let's say they have them,
but uh,
someone flying Spaghetti Monster for bid decides to blow up a school or a
footlocker in a mall or a stadium or a concert venue.
Those machines are going to be everywhere.
What do you think would happen if you went to the airport and you had like a
radiation detector and you said,
I would like to go through this machine and [inaudible] they wouldn't let you.
There's no way they would let you,
it's probably arrest you,
right?
Yeah.
What does that machinery,
you're not allowed to have it here.
They creep in.
My incident in Austin,
I was told I was not allowed to film it.
I was brought into a private,
secrete,
a screening room that had a giant placard above.
It says this is a private screening room,
which I did not request.
I was taken in there.
My belongings were taken in there without my request.
I even objected to it and they said,
you have to go this way.
Did you have to,
is that the law yet?
At this point I didn't have time to fight and I had to catch a flight.
See the thing is with the Patriot Act and shit like that,
you don't know what the fuck is.
Terrorism on paper these days get up as they go along and then they have lawyers
figure out how,
what however they treated you is the legal way to treat you.
Sons of bitches,
we going bitch,
they had the x ray get bagger.
I gotta,
I gotta have you pull something up.
They have the x ray machine in the Austin airport and it's right next to one of
those rapid scan body scanning machines,
right?
And there's a long line for the rapid scan machine and that's when they say,
oh that lines get long.
Come on through the x rays.
So right away I'm like,
you know what,
if this is integral to my safety,
you're now chucking my safety out the window for the convenience factor of
cycling people through security.
Well they really sang that it's not safe.
And these are really what they're saying the rabbits can thing or the,
no,
no.
I'm talking about,
I'm talking about if we need those,
those body scanning machines because they can detect a whole bunch of stuff that
a traditional x ray can't.
When it gets to inconvenient because the line is too long,
you're now throwing my safety out the window.
That seems inconsistent.
Sound seems wrong,
right?
It's crazy.
But I'm in line to go through the x ray and then randomly they do the,
you need to go through the rapid scan machine.
So I said,
can I just go through the x Ray?
No,
you can't.
Now they're angry with me because I even asked that.
So I opt out as I normally do,
my belongings go through the machine.
Now I can't see them.
I say,
Hey,
I can't see my laptop.
I can't see my phone.
I can't seem to that stuff.
It's over there.
You're leaving.
Your belongings are fine.
How do I know that?
I can't see them.
They didn't give anybody to do it.
So I'm already on edge.
Right.
I always hit it.
Always feel like whenever I take a fucking jet blue flight,
this is gonna be my occupied moment.
It's gonna end with pepper spray to the face and I'm gonna get handcuffed even
though miss politesse can be.
And I just,
I just want someone to watch my shit right.
I get stuck in a glass box where I'm next to a girl that couldn't have been more
than six years old.
Um,
she has a,
uh,
a handicap.
She's in a wheelchair and there was something mentally wrong with her.
She was stemming,
she was rocking.
She was pulling her hair and crying because there were three TSA agents trying
to tell her to lift her arms so they can swab her clothes,
swab her wheelchair,
the back pad,
the tires,
the wheels,
everything.
Her Dad is there on the brink.
You can imagine how traumatic it is to try to bring somebody in a special needs
child through an airport in general.
But now they've been selected for special screening and he has to try to explain
to his daughter who was having a fit.
Rightfully so,
and strangers are groping her and Swiping,
swabbing her seat.
He's trying to calm her down.
Well,
you know,
by holding an iPad and her face and doing whatever he can to get her to relax.
Do I have to lift her out of the seat?
He asked.
Yes you do.
He's trying to lift her up.
She's fighting it.
My heart is breaking for this guy.
The reason I'm sitting in this glass box is because after my pat down,
they ran my little piece of cloth or they ran the gloves and the piece of cloth
that they swiped the bottom of my feet with through a machine.
By the way,
machines would we,
which we spent more than $30 million on to install an airports in this machine.
Said I tested positive for nitrates.
I had that will happen one.
Yeah,
and I pulled up.
So what's a nitrate?
Well,
sir,
it's a,
you know,
that can be used.
It's a chemical.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Well,
it's a chemical be used in a lot of things.
It doesn't,
this isn't,
it's not a bad thing.
It's not a bad thing.
I'm like,
this isn't a problem.
And I go,
no,
it is a problem because I have a flight to catch and I want to know like why I'm
being detained longer.
While you're tested positive for nitrates,
we have to give you a,
an even more thorough screening.
Okay,
well what else can test positive for nitrates?
Guy Couldn't answer it.
Second person couldn't answer it.
Third Person says Q if you had been to a farm.
No they did not.
But the third guy finally said,
well the,
the head of the,
the security mob there said,
well if you've walked on grass that has fertilizer on it,
then you might test positive for nitrates.
Even a certain heart medications that seniors take tests positive for nitrates.
So I'm now stuck in a glass box,
detached from my valuables watching this poor girl having a meltdown as these
three people are going to love her and I start to cry because it just,
it breaks my heart that this is happening.
This poor guy is having to go through this and I,
you know,
I go to put my hand on a shoulder and tell him like,
I'm sorry,
you have to go through this.
And he looks back and he's choked up.
I mean,
he's been in there for a good 15 minutes trying to calm down his daughter.
So then I start questioning,
why are you guys doing this?
And I'm being polite and being calm,
being everything you could possibly be.
Well,
asking how much longer this is going to take because I have a to catch.
They grab my belongings and start walking them away and it go,
excuse me.
What are you doing?
Like you're,
you're coming here to this private screening room?
No,
no,
no.
I don't want to be in a private screening room.
I want this enhanced pat down to happen right here because I want my girlfriend
to videotape it.
Well,
no,
no sir.
You're going by this time my belongings are in the frosted glass private
screening room.
Now I'm in the private screening room with them and there's a giant placard that
says,
this is a private security room.
There was no filming whatsoever.
If a train,
if a TSA employee tells you to stop filming,
you must seats filling immediately.
You do have the right to call in a witness to be there.
And I'm thinking,
why can't the camera be my witness?
Because if I'm traveling alone,
who else am I gonna call fucking Ghostbusters?
And they gonna Bring Tsa in here.
So when I'm in a glass box with two dudes by myself,
he swabs me down with the gloves and then he says,
I'll be right back.
I have to test this glove goes,
puts his hand on the handle of the door with the glove on it that he just wiped
me down,
opens it up and walks out on his merry way.
So I looked to the other guy who's left in the room.
I'm like,
what the fuck was that?
And it was like the first time I had cursed and he goes,
what do you mean?
I'm like,
he just swapped my body down with that glove.
Then grabbed the handle.
If someone in her earlier did have explosives on them and he grabbed that handle
with that glove.
That's now on my test.
Why is any testing right here?
There's a machine in the room.
Oh Sir.
That that machine's calibration is off.
That's why it's here.
Uh,
it happened in the room cause the calibration is off.
Yeah,
there's a tag on it that says it needs to be serviced.
Okay.
So I'm waiting five minutes go by.
I'd strike up conversation with the guy.
I hate that that little girl out there in the wheelchair that's having the fit
and I can still hear her having a poor meltdown out there.
Why are they out there?
Well he tested positive for nitrates as well.
Oh he did?
Yeah.
Why is the girl there?
Oh she tested positive for nitrates.
Oh.
So all three of us have tested positive for nitrates with the one machine that's
out there.
You've got another one in here that need servicing and recalibration and you
think there's nothing wrong with this situation.
Guy Comes back,
tells me I'm clear.
I leave the room and I see the father is still there struggling with his
daughter and I'm like,
I'm again like moved to tears.
And I asked this guy,
tell me as a human being,
do you think this is right?
Do you think this treatment for this poor girl is right?
And he goes,
sir,
she tested positive for nitrates and went right.
I get that.
But there are many other countries who deal with terrorism on a far greater
level than we do who have far more swifter and more and more common sense
approach to security that doesn't demean their citizenry.
That doesn't cost them millions of taxpayer dollars.
Do you think that that's right,
that that girl is having a meltdown,
you're swabbing her wheelchair,
do you really think she's a terrorist?
I'm just asking you as a human being.
And there was a long pause and he sort of looked down and looked at his shoes
and I thought,
good,
I'm finally going to have a moment,
a real moment here as a human being is going to take off that TSA helmet for a
second.
And he looked up and looked me right in the eyes and said she tested positive
for nitrates and that's when I realized this is a,
this is a lost cause.
This is a losing battle here.
What a Burger King employee.
I used to joke about it that I think that the people who work at security and
the people that work at Burger King or like the same people,
it's just a reached a hand into a bucket.
Well,
you today,
oh,
I got fries.
Damn,
I got bombed control.
Yup.
I'm on foot swabbing or I'm on rubbing beltline.
Here's my security.
Today is I,
dude,
I hate mopping that fucking floor.
I'm all for people having jobs,
but we need repair infrastructure.
Run after school programs.
Do something that benefits your community and society more than this.
I see.
I think that we need security of Europe.
We just,
because there's been so many instances in the past of people using airplanes,
hijacking airplanes.
I believe that reinforcing of the doors was the best thing that happened.
That was the one security measure that said,
look,
we know we're now as a society.
No one will ever hijack a plane again if it's sourced in America.
If it's one out of here,
everybody in that cabin will fight and die to make sure that plane doesn't get
hijacked and air marshals to,
I think Eric Schlosser important too.
I think it's good to have a guy up there is an actual bad motherfucker who knows
how to take care of Shit.
If some wacky motherfucker tries to blow his shoes up and some people even make
the argument by the way,
that that gun's on planes would have stopped some of nine 11 that if someone
actually had a gun on that flight,
you know,
in the risk of a bullet going through and that sudden loss of cabin pressure is
overrated.
I don't know that I subscribed to that,
but I could see how that's a valid argument.
I could see how someone could make that.
We do need security,
but the,
the,
the leaps and bounds that we've gone to are inefficient.
They don't work.
It's costing us millions and millions of dollars.
The company,
the companies suck and they're dealing with gigantic numbers of employees
because they have these setups at every God damn airport and every God damn city
all over this country.
There's a lot of fucking airports.
So there's no way they're really paying attention and monitoring it at all.
A really intense level and looking at it like how can we make this a better
experience for the people except for like those things where you go and you,
you put your name in and you get scanned and then he'd go through pre like Tsa
pre like the blue where the clear programs now that,
and now that I have another,
another issue with that,
because sometimes you have to pay more to now they're creating another tiered
society where the haves don't get,
have the inconvenience on hate on the 1% dude just because they want to get
through the airport.
Me One of the guys that can afford the premium tickets.
So I get through the TSA like I'm,
I'm blessed,
I live a good life.
Listen,
listen motherfucker,
I'm blessed and show me the keys to your car.
Yeah.
The keys to the kingdom is maybe a seven.
I love it.
Oh my God.
Nice car.
Thank you.
I love it.
Wow.
What space ship.
That's a space and the technology in it.
Like I need some pretty close to a car that drives itself.
Like I don't touch the gas pedal anymore.
Yeah.
This is the Audi a seven which they passed today by the way.
Self driving cars and cars.
Let's do it.
Awesome.
But even with the old cars,
mine has the adaptive cruise where you pressed the button,
it'll automatically stay with,
you know,
it'll match pace with the car in Florida.
So I don't really even on surface streets,
like city streets,
I don't really touch the gas pedal.
I get it up to speed,
hit a button and I kind of,
yeah,
it's easier to send tweets that way.
Oh.
And s but there has been,
there has been a time or two where I will,
I'm just kind of zoning out.
I'm not using my phone,
but I am like,
oh the car's driving itself and all of a sudden bleeding.
And they had the heads up display.
So it puts my miles per hour and my turn by turn,
like on the windshield,
like you're seeing it out through there.
It turns bright red and it's like warning collision.
So I have to slam on the breaks and I'm like fucking r two d two fell asleep at
my wheel.
Fucking short circuit was not paying attention.
I almost slammed into the car and for them someone just get in front of you
really quick?
No,
I mean we've just casually going,
I mean it's much safer to use those systems on a highway where there might not
be so much start and stop.
Oh,
so it hiccups but I,
yeah,
I mean it's sometimes it's a little lax.
I'm sure it's busy processing my Bluetooth audio and goes,
Oh shit,
you're driving.
It has the switch over to that.
My favorite car that I have is my Porsche because it's beautiful.
The race car,
the GT three because it doesn't have anything in it.
It has navigation with the navigation says it had seats in the back.
No,
no,
she's exactly,
it has nothing.
And then not only that,
it's like it doesn't do anything.
Like there's no heads up display.
There's no,
it's just mechanical.
It's just a machine.
And you shift the gears yourself.
You don't,
you don't allow the thing to stop and break for you to say like the exact
opposite.
But that does get tiring for a lot of people.
Especially dude,
I got to browse reddit.
Like I don't have time to shift gears.
I got to catch up on my news.
Do you realize you're joking around about that but you really shouldn't.
I don't want,
I don't really look when you're shown you in your car now and no one,
no one should live out rape fantasies either.
Some girls like that though.
I don't think anybody likes running.
So overall drive cause they were tweeting while driving.
Yeah.
It's uh,
eventually it's going to be really smooth.
We are going to be able to accomplish that stuff as you're driving.
But I don't even trust people to you.
Do you even pull the largest pass for self driving cars?
How do you feel about that?
And California,
they're street legal.
It's been effective.
They've been using it in,
Google's been using it for quite a while.
You could,
you could find it online.
The only known collision,
or at least like six months ago when I was reading about it,
the only known collision and one of those Google self driving cars was when the
operator took it out of self-drive node was manually driving it,
but he still had to document it because it was a collision with a car.
Well,
I think that I enjoy driving.
I enjoy the experience of,
of shifting my own gears.
I think I look at like when you have a,
a fun car,
like the,
the Gt three driving becomes like a ride.
I took a ride home.
Right.
But not when you have a commute.
Yeah.
That's not fun.
Like shifting gears when you're stopped on the four oh five and holding in a
clutch.
Yeah.
That's shitty.
And so to let my car drive and maybe free me up to do an extra hours productive
work or focus on my book on tape and my mind,
my audible.com/joe download to focus on that.
That makes sense to me.
Oh totally.
But you know,
it doesn't make sense.
That kind of traffic.
Do you see?
We got a fuck nights.
We can figure out that it's not gossip here anytime soon.
I am going to disappear.
I'm not going to live like this my whole life.
I tried escaping me.
Go to the mound and try again.
I don't know.
I'm thinking maybe Santa Barbara.
I'm,
I might try Santa Barbara for a while cause it's only like an hour live in the
zoo.
You're going to have them,
you a,
you should have them build you a little cabin and the chip bums me out.
We might be living in a fucking zoo.
How about that pal?
How about this whole planet might be a zoo.
Look at this robot guy with as Google glass.
Oh my God,
it creates bars.
And did you check out black mirror by the way?
You guys look at that shit.
Did you watch that?
No,
no,
no.
So many things to Montana.
But I did see the little Wayne deposition.
You just see that the one that's been making zero,
Brian thought to pull it up because I just became a little Wayne Fan.
Oh,
me too.
I was not a little Wayne fan up until this.
I loved that.
It wasn't that Chappelle skit of I plead the fifth.
Yeah.
And I'm thinking of getting a little Wayne Tattoo.
That's how bad ass this dude is.
Yeah,
man,
he's good.
He's suing these people because they made a documentary about him and apparently
has a lot of false information according to Mr Wayne.
And so they asked him a bunch of stupid questions at this deposition,
but the way he answered it was beautiful.
It was hilarious.
The veiled threat,
which many have donated say don't even say,
I don't want to spoil it.
We we're going to play it.
Hm.
It happened just a couple of days ago.
It's pretty great and it's hard to get without the Worldstar hip hop.
Uh,
that is my new homepage.
What does that,
the watermark.
Watermarks.
I love me some world star hip hop.
Yeah.
That's my problem.
If you go to my computer and you type in WWE in the browser,
it just goes,
he knows I want to see some fucked up.
Why are you going to watch that Kanye sex tape when it leaks on that site?
Is there two of them?
Two of them.
Kanye West has sex tapes.
Jeezy really?
There's a rumor that one of them is with that,
with the Kardashians,
but apparently it's a look a like girl from there.
Do they have a video of her from some booty shaking contest,
which I love it.
That he competitive sport.
Is he doing this on purpose releasing these?
Uh,
he's apparently offered millions of dollars to stop the release,
so I don't,
I don't know.
I doubt at his level at this point while the girls were releasing it,
no,
I think there were stolen off of his computer stolen,
stolen,
which,
who knows if someone that physically stole them or hacked in or whatever.
But that's,
that's what I read.
Is this it?
Oh,
animal practice.
It's watching Bobby Lee.
How would you describe your image in the media?
How would I describe my image in the media?
Yes,
I wouldn't describe it.
Well,
how would you describe it if you had to?
I don't have to.
Well,
what do you make sure you portrayed in the media?
I don't portray anything.
I am who I am.
And you guys portray what you,
again,
who are you?
Who is the real him?
Dwayne Michael Carter Junior.
Okay.
Do you,
uh,
like to portray yourself as I just asked at that and said that I don't like to
portray myself as nobody
be Dwayne,
Michael Carter,
Johnny.
I don't portray myself as anything.
An image is self described.
Well you have to wait until I'm done with the quest.
You don't have to wait to anything.
I honestly,
I,
I mean this guy right here,
me telling me that I have to wait,
but I don't have to do math.
Go ahead,
ask the question.
Your honor.
Do you like to save you?
Right in the real world,
that guy right there,
he can't save you in the railroad.
She's just like,
what does that mean?
I don't have to elaborate.
Okay.
Is that your next question?
Is that a threat against,
I miss noticed that.
Can you just ask your next question please.
Progression of time.
The hoodie is off.
He can't save you
and what does that mean?
I was talking to myself.
Oh my God,
he can't save you in the real world.
this,
he's a beautiful human being.
Great.
Fuck you to that lawyer.
That was beautiful.
Yeah,
that was big because that guy was talking to him in that like weird formal speak
that you have to do if you'd give a deposition.
Right.
That's like not human.
It's like,
it's weird.
It does it.
It takes,
it's almost like removing a lot of context or moving a lot of,
they speak like text messages.
There's no emotion,
there's no context.
It's just,
it's,
it's a legal document flowing out of someone's mouth because he's writing the
question,
these transcribing it as he goes,
it needs to sound legally correct.
Well,
I thought it was brilliant that he was trying to get a little Wayne to define
himself.
Right,
and what bullshit question.
Yeah.
How would you describe the media's portrayal?
I wouldn't.
And it also depends what site,
what outlet you don't have.
Would you describe the media's portrayal of you,
Joe?
A fear factor guy.
Really?
You think that's still,
that's still the case.
The UFC guy,
maybe.
Maybe the UFC guy.
He had a little midget me that,
but doesn't it depend on what outlet?
Yeah.
Well it depends on whether they like you and they don't like him exist.
Sure.
For sure.
It depends on whether or not they have a motivation.
I think it's pretty clear at this point that what you're getting in the news is
not just the information of all the things.
It's happening all over the world.
It's,
they have an agenda.
Right.
And if their agenda is to mock you,
uh,
you know,
if you were a celebrity who they love,
they might talk about you and glowing terms or if you're a celebrity,
you get arrested because you slammed your SUV into a pole while doing rails and
cocaine.
It's like,
no,
they wouldn't then,
then,
then they always talk down on you.
But I'm saying it depends on the celebrity.
You could be like a person,
like,
uh,
like Jennifer Lopez is getting married and that's a piece of news.
Or You could be like,
Lindsay Lohan crashed her car again,
I think.
And well I think it does depend on the celebrity cause I think like what Gibson
had another,
oops see today on the side of the road because they hate that guy.
That guy's done.
But there are some celebrities that they treat the kid gloves because they're
worried they won't sit down for the next junket to promote their movie.
I don't think there's a bit,
I don't think anymore,
man.
I really don't think too many people get,
like,
I've worked in it too much to know what people will say and won't say because
they're afraid they'll lose it.
Feel like when you get like a certain level of fucked up at Nesto drunk driving,
you drown in a barrel.
All bets are off.
But there are some,
they'll forgive some celebrities and they'll forgive some personalities if they
feel like later on it might be,
it might benefit them or if they're worried,
certainly if they're trying to get more interviews,
right.
Yes.
Yeah.
They were worried about pulling the thing,
pulling about d like apple is one of those companies that blogs are afraid to
write about.
It's a bit of a tangent,
but they're afraid to write about them in certain negative ways because they're
worried they won't be allowed into their conference or get an early review unit.
Right.
That has happened.
They pulled all the,
all the plugs for Gizmodo.
Once Gizmodo leaked that iPhone,
that iPhone stuff,
once they got the guy's iPhone from the bar,
Oh,
that's right.
Before they said,
fuck you Gizmodo.
We'll never get a thing against.
Never get a unit.
To this day,
they still don't know we can get in there.
They're not going to forget those grudges.
Wow.
How rude.
Apple Steve Jobs is dead.
Can't we all just get along?
You fucks.
You get into five.
What's this black mirror black mirror violently on this last podcast and
everybody was like,
thank you so much for introducing me to this.
There's,
this is just one of the episodes here.
There it is the best.
It's a channel four mini series.
I don't need to Belabor it because I did it last time.
And what's it about again,
it's about like near future societal issues that will come about because of the
rapid changing pace of technology.
That is the,
that is the seed that that sprouts each of the three episodes and they're all
completely different.
Completely different aesthetics,
completely different directors,
but they're all fascinating.
They're phenomenally written.
Interesting that we're talking about it as like,
like problems in the future.
It's really not problems were the problem.
The reality is the assimilation is the societal issues because like we were
talking about Google glasses,
right?
When you have the ability to,
to life of log when the devices light enough,
powerful enough,
cheap enough and easy enough to,
I record 24 hours here,
whatever I see and I can play it back like that.
That's what one of the issues or one of the episodes is about.
So you watch a couple try to navigate a relationship where every moment is
fucking recorded.
So he's like,
I want to see what happened June 12th when you were with that guy at 3:00 PM
show me that moment.
Pull it up.
You know,
she's frantically trying to delete it.
Hey,
when we had that argument two hours ago,
you said this and it really upset me.
I didn't say it like that.
Oh yeah,
boom.
Pull that moment and look at it.
That's a shoe that will happen.
There's a commercial that they were running really recently about a dash cam.
They sell dash cams now.
So,
uh,
the guy pulls over someone and he's like,
this is a re re enactment of an actual accident in New York City.
And the woman goes,
this guy hit me.
And the guy goes up to the cop and says,
would you like me to tell you what happened?
Or show you what happened?
And the cops have,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I have a dashboard camera and it shows them the camera and clearly shows the
woman hitting him.
Right?
So he goes,
ma'am,
let me just tell you,
that line to an officer is,
you know,
a crime.
Do you want to go to jail?
Tell him the truth.
And she is okay.
I hit him.
Yeah.
I pull.
If you search for a Russia search for Russian Dash Cam or Russian Insurance
Fraud Dash Cam,
hold on.
Is that bad?
What?
Cause the same size.
The guys protected from accidental.
That seems good.
And maybe like a cop beating your ass.
That's,
that's another possibility.
I,
some cop was having a hard day decides to kick your ass cause he thinks no one's
watching.
But I certainly didn't mean to imply that that technology will only lead to
negative societal consequences.
This mini series just happens to explore them.
And that was the when you get to release.
Yeah,
it does it in a beautiful poetic way.
With that said,
I'm a,
I,
you know this,
I'm a proponent of the,
you know,
the point of singularity now Lord,
I want,
I want transcendence,
transcendental wisdom.
Like put as much ps plastic.
Put PC parts in me.
Exactly.
Let's go.
I put it in me.
I wanted to get RFID chip back when [inaudible] first came out so I could have
all my,
my,
my credit cards,
my remote entry and my badges to my work.
I wanted them all to be put in there so I get to swipe my hand.
You know,
that was one thing that the,
what do you watch and Brian's this an accident.
Yeah.
I think what happened is this lady backs into a Coppin and get,
what I'm guessing is that she's going to say something like,
you ran into the back.
There are great videos of like people in China and Russia like running at cars
that are parked in the streets and then leaping onto the hoods and rolling off
and getting up and going,
oh,
I'm black,
but they're literally charging the car.
We just sang before Brian showed this video talking about transhumanism,
about the RFID chip,
where you swipe and how to put into the,
mythbusters said that that was the one episode that they were not allowed to
air.
They couldn't do an episode on the RFID chips.
They were told by their net worth that that was a subject of interest.
They could not explore you.
What happened with those guys?
I don't know if you heard the story,
but they were going to do it and the like the guys behind the RFID tag and chip
makers said,
yeah,
we just want to get on the phone with you to discuss the technology and discuss
the show before we help you out or whatever.
And so they hopped on the line and on the other side of the line was like 40
lawyers from credit card companies,
from security firms saying,
you cannot do this episode.
You cannot talk about RFID.
It is the most unsecure fucking system in the world.
Absolutely unsecure.
You can build cheap Pringles can readers for them,
pull the data right off of them.
You can hack them,
you can clone them.
There's a good videos of the,
uh,
okay,
well why don't you explain to everybody who doesn't know what the fuck does RFID
mean?
It's remote.
I believe it's remote frequency identification.
It's basically a thing of the chip,
the size of a grain of rice or sometimes they're like flat.
They're very,
very low to no power devices that can be passively read.
So if you have a beacon,
a reader,
they even like the whole thing in your phone,
they could put it in your clothes on clothes.
They use it like a security systems in malls when you walk through a reader,
that's because a lot of them are RFID based.
It as paying the the product and that sent it off and said,
okay,
this is,
you know,
a security barrier being reached.
Those little like credit cards when you tap them to readers.
A lot of that is RFID.
Some of it is near field communication,
which is a slightly different standard that's coming about now.
But there is a lot of RFID swiping for security and buildings that all exists.
It's been hacked to high heaven.
You can buy RFID readers,
you can read all the information,
you can hack it passports that have RFID and I'm now they're very unsafe.
Uh,
you know,
people pull out your info,
they can clone it,
they can copy it.
You know,
I am not entirely sure there's great videos of BMWs now being hacked.
Um,
they sell blank keys that you can code the wireless Keystart on them and there's
a pretty easy process to just pop it into the car and have it right.
The new key code to it,
like a dealer kind of thing and you can start the cars and drive off.
Now they fixed it sentence and it's not just not just a BMW thing,
but these guys can be Fred and hacked and that's why they went,
they didn't want the mythbusters to talk about it.
Cause we're now building foundations and we're building institutions in our
daily lives that are,
that are built on
fault,
faulty security premises.
Like we're all becoming very comfortable with near field communication and
tapping things and whatever.
And you have to completely hackable and easily cloned and easily broken.
Is it something that can be fixed in the future and they don't want to alert
people before they develop a fix for it?
Well,
I'd look they,
if they've invested millions of dollars in,
in creating new systems,
in transitioning their key cards and passports to this technology,
the last thing they want is a security concern.
But this is an age old problem.
Security is always an issue.
It's built by a human being.
It will be broken by a human being.
So there's no really fixing it.
You can make it stronger,
you can make it smarter.
Sure.
There's no real fixing it.
Like so the,
the,
the future of the world when,
when it comes to technology and,
and it is dependent upon our cooperation because at some point in time we're
going to all have access to,
to anything.
Like essentially we're going to all be readable everywhere we go.
Sure.
Yeah.
All the testing that we're heading that way right now,
it's almost like it's setting itself up so that no one can ever really,
truly be in control.
And that it does have to be a sort of a group decision at the very top because
at a certain point in time,
like right now,
who's track in what regard?
Like,
well,
what I'm saying is right now,
if you're looking at technology right now,
the government's tracking us should they have a gps in your phone.
So Facebook and apple,
there's gps on your phone.
The GPS in their phone knows exactly where your location is,
but at a certain point in time,
I'm going to know where your location is too.
It's not going to just be,
the government is going to be anybody who wants to know.
It's going to get to a point where everything is going to be accessible.
Well,
we'll accept that for convenience.
Like there are apps now that allow me to like find my friends or there's a an
app where I can send you a temporary gps tracking token for my phone.
So for all trying to meet up at a restaurant or an amusement park,
you don't have to text me and say,
dude,
where are you?
You can pull me up on a map and see that I'm five minutes away and it didn't
give you what street I'm on.
So we'll accept some of that in the name of convenience,
but fun and fun,
kind of fun.
It's fun.
Your friend Coachella,
oh,
hey look,
we're all a little dots running around.
Let's play PAC man game.
That's really dope actually.
Yeah,
no,
that will be cool and we'll accept that to an extent,
but then we will also have privacy controls,
which a will likely be able to be hacked.
Of course be the government will not,
they'll ignore those.
They went from Maine.
They fucking will though,
and they say,
what did you see that they have that apple has a,
it's a trademark or a patent on a technology that allows the government to
disable the recording of the phone.
Yes.
It'll allows people to shut off the phones,
video capabilities remotely so that you can't Protan a videotape protests or or
whatnot.
They don't specifically say protest.
The best reason for it was dirty is what they say.
Why would security,
why would it ever be in your best interest and not be able to videotape?
We need a new digital bill of rights that says that if,
by the way,
let me just say for the record,
that they're,
the reason for developing this technology is that apple is involved in many
patent lawsuits and all.
And so when it comes to the ability to record
bands,
the ability,
I mean,
you're getting to a point where,
you know,
the new phone has eight megapixels,
the fucking video's fantastic.
You can almost get something that's,
you could,
you could put out and it would be a really good version of it.
And the problem with that is you could record people and then put their shit
online,
right?
So they want to be able to have a concert and say,
well,
you can't record this concept.
Especially for standup comedians.
It becomes a real problem when you go,
you went to town and everybody's now everybody knows your shit.
Yeah.
So that's apples.
I ideas that they would set it up so that if there was a concert,
you couldn't record the concert,
they would shut off there.
But they,
but a,
I still think that's a huge security concern.
I mean that could,
that could be a wild security concern.
It's an awesome move for fucking Samsung because everybody's going to want to go
android.
Oh yeah,
exactly.
Like fuck this.
Or they'll build the feature into their phones and then have to pay apple
millions of dollars once they sue one of the two cap in their work.
There's a great app,
I,
the name is escaping me,
but it actually stitches together multiple recordings based off of visual cues
and like audio,
like wave forms and Tom Codes.
So if you're at a concert,
if you're out of Coachella and there's 40 people in the crowd that are filming
it with their Iphones,
they can all upload their video and it will stitch those angles together as best
as it can.
So you can kind of jump around.
That's bad.
That's getting awesome.
Yeah.
Oh my fucking cool dude.
That's a mind fuck and a half isn't it?
But you won't be using it and streaming it live thanks to Verizon's data caps.
What is browse data caps now company that's selling any company that's selling
limited data plans right now is stifling innovation and fucking consumers over
and fucking over entire does travel limited,
rented the only one but they barely have a network.
They have a decent network.
They have an own union with dude for Tang and good.
It's not,
it's,
it's uh,
it's a shadow of what a t and t and Verizon provides as far as four g may be.
Absolutely not as hierarchy,
date coverage.
No,
no,
no.
And it's fine for coverage.
But the,
the problem is that now we're training,
uh,
customers and consumers to second guess their decisions when it comes to data.
Like could you imagine on your home computer second guessing downloading world
of Warcraft where you might,
cause you don't play it,
but downloading a movie,
streaming Netflix because you're worried about the mudroom,
worried about the data caps.
Now we're going back,
we're regressing from unlimited back to the days of,
you got 93 hours or four free megs on prodigy.
So it used to be unlimited.
And then with the iPhone,
it really kind of clogged up the network.
Right.
That's the dose in general with smartphones in general,
that signal the shift from being a traditional voice device to now I rarely make
calls on my phone.
I'm sending texts,
I'm streaming videos,
I'm tweeting,
I'm on Reddit.
Like never talk on the phone.
Yeah,
yeah.
And we Skype because it's easier to see it.
I feel like you're so close to me and said,
telling me through the Internet.
But to that point,
I did like to Skype sessions on the road with a Verizon little four g hotspot,
little jetpack,
and I used up 3.9 gigs and just like an hour of video chat.
And so now it was bad.
I was afraid to check emails and do work and I'm like,
this is bad for an entire industry.
This will stifle innovation because the next day the Instagram of video might
not get created if it takes up too much band.
Well,
why is cellular so much more expensive than canned?
Is that all it is?
Because they can't.
They would say it's because it's more expensive to launch the satellites and
the,
the bandwidth itself is crazy expensive.
It's really,
I mean you can throttle during peak usage,
but there's no reason to limit how much data I can suck down at 3:00 AM your
network is not that congested,
you know the air.
Is there more expensive for them if people use more or is it there it's not
taxing on their system and their infrastructure?
That's what to ask you or is it that their system can't handle it?
Sure.
I mean that at some point,
yes it gets to that.
But it's,
so that's a way of limiting yet by getting people to pay more.
Right.
But the price of bay,
I mean there's been studies that show that what you pay now for bandwidth,
even though it is more expensive and it's faster,
what you pay now for bandwidth is exponentially higher than what you used to
pay.
Bandwidth should be getting cheaper.
And the,
the problem that I had,
like I went in to get a jet pack from Verizon and a,
you have to pay to be a new customer,
right?
That's just to put you in a system.
You have to pay for the SIM card essentially that they're gonna pop into your,
they're gonna device.
You're going to tether it to the account.
You have to pay for the device itself,
sign up for a contract.
Then with their data plans,
you have to pay for the data.
You have to buy the bandwidth,
the four gigs a month,
and you have to pay extra to tethered to the device that you just bought that
you're under contract for.
So you have to pay to tether that to the data.
Like I don't mean to get on the nerdiest soapbox in the fucking world,
but that is bullshit.
That's like going into a restaurant,
paying to go into the door,
paying to sit down for your table,
ordering water.
You have to pay for the water,
pay for the cup that it's going to go into.
And then when you go to drink the water,
they're like,
no,
no.
You have to tether a straw to that water.
I know you just bought that one and you're paying monthly.
You're paying out the ass for it even though it's just coming from a garden
hose,
but you've got to pay to tether a straw to sit that water.
It's fucking highway robbery.
Is that going to get better?
Maybe.
How,
how can you,
how can you fix that?
You'd have to have more companies getting,
there's gotta be collusion going on because once,
once,
once Verizon announces we're going to do this type of a data plan at t and t
follow suit,
sooner or later,
Sprint will,
once the network gets more popular and the advices gets sold there rising can't,
you can't use data and calls at the same time.
Even under four g under the new phone and a new on the new iPhone.
You can,
I think you can on Lte,
can you not can or is it refers to the three g network when you're talking again
on every single phone except the iPhone on Verizon's network.
You can or can't.
You cans can.
Fantastic.
You can't do,
you can't.
You can't do it on the iPhone,
but you can do that on every single,
on every other phone.
So if you buy like the galaxy s three you can do it.
I fucking,
I love the galaxy.
I hate those commercials.
No better way to make me not give a shit about your product.
Then by spending three minutes of airtime telling me that I'm a Douche by you
watching commercials.
I don't watch commercial.
They happen before web videos now and sometimes they're hard to skip.
I just fucking what if it was my eyes and hit mute.
What do you think about the Samsung Note?
Me Bitch.
Have you played with that?
I haven't really thought about the no much.
No kind of guy.
The galaxy note phone,
that's sort of a half time.
We reviewed it on attack when I was still there.
Yes,
it's delicious.
Holding a giant tablet to
take hands doesn't bother me.
I like it.
It looks like a Bluetooth headset on you.
It does not on me.
Not on me.
I need it in my life.
You haven't seen those commercials where they show that people waiting in line
for the iPhone.
It makes them look like assholes.
Talking about the incremental features.
I'm like,
listen,
spend your 30 seconds telling me why your phone is better,
which they barely do in the commercial.
They did spend time trying to make me feel like an asshole because they use an
iPhone.
I'm not opposed to a device.
It's no,
it's a nickel tactic at all.
It's a terrible tactic.
It's like because it may want to talk to a guy like me,
one of Obama,
so sell his product.
He's selling Mitt Romney by making fun of Obama.
I mean that's what he's doing.
He's doing a great job of selling it to.
He knows he has to get just the 53% of the country that pays taxes.
Those freeloaders don't care about them.
It's everybody.
Anybody who doesn't pay income tax,
he didn't give a fuck about.
That was one of the biggest gaps in political history.
Daf though.
No,
it's not.
Well,
it is a gap because you don't think George Bush,
senior,
George Bush w you don't think those guys think the exact same.
That's what I mean.
Yeah.
It was a gap in the sense that it got out and he said it,
but that's what they really think.
Course he's a business to what they think.
There's never been a businessman that looked out for people and you think about
a guy like,
and he's a ruthless businessman.
When you get to be the Bain capital of the world,
you get hundreds of millions of dollars of profit,
ladies and gentlemen.
You don't do it by doing what's best for people you're doing by.
You do it by doing what's best for your company.
You do it by maximizing one's and zero's.
That's it,
and you do.
You do it at the expense of humanity.
It's a creepy I.
There is no whole on the spreadsheet.
You're a one or a zero.
You're a bottom line to a business is this smacks of racist.
I'm like,
I am not an Obama Fan.
I do not like what he's done as far as civil liberties coat.
I think as a human being,
he seems like a great guy.
I don't understand why such a shit president because as a human being,
I see he,
he,
the way he interacts with people,
he seems like a genuine fund guy.
Like the way you hear stories of him in college,
a lot of weed,
but it's,
it's,
it's super,
super disappointing to me.
And then I,
but there's a big difference between him and Mitt Romney.
Mitt Romney is a creepy ass businessman and the idea that this guy being a
businessman would somehow another be better for this country.
I don't believe you think that.
I think you're racist.
I saw,
I think it is.
I think there's a lot of people that just want to believe that Mitt Romney would
do a better job because he's a businessman and he would get things done.
And you don't Mar Obama's for the distribution of wealth,
but then when you add your press them about it,
they really don't even know what the fuck that means.
90% of the people that talk about Obama being for the risk of redistribution of
wealth,
they don't even understand what the real concern amongst these socialist ideas
or most of what he's saying.
It's really not a redistribution of wealth in the classical sense.
It's not,
it's not like trying to steal money from people and Robin Hood the Motherfucker,
but you talked to a guy like Mitt Romney and he will put ones and Zeros ahead of
people for fucking sure.
And he will think that if rich people get richer,
they will make more jobs for the poor people and the poor people will be okay
and he will cut away funding and he will.
He will ultimately do things that are not good for people that are struggling.
I,
that's what I believe.
When when you,
when you talk about his tax policies and you find out that middleclass people
will actually have to pay more money,
2000 and average $2,000 more per year.
Fuck you man.
Fuck you.
For a guy who paid 14% yeah.
It's incredible that people would say that this guy seems like he'd be a good
choice.
I say even for what he's saying he would do.
I don't believe that he's going to do anything he says he'll do because Obama
didn't do anything.
He said he would do.
It didn't close down Guantanamo Bay.
He didn't stop fucking with the medical pot shops.
He didn't do anything he said he was going to do.
He didn't pull out of Iraq until years after he did.
He's says,
we're still there by the way.
We never really pull out.
You have a fucking enormous base.
They're filled with soldiers.
There's no pulling out.
There's no pulling out anywhere.
We have bases in a hundred countries plus so,
but just once he met Jerome 2016 just with Mitt Romney says he would do,
I'm like,
you really want that?
Fuck you man.
Fuck you.
You don't want that.
You just want a white guy.
You want to,
I've talked to people,
I'm like listening to the things they're saying and they don't even really know
what the Fuck Mitt Romney stands for.
They don't know what he's done.
And I think that's,
I think that is true.
I don't necessarily know that their decision though is rooted in racism.
I think it's just kind of rooted in a general ignorance about what he's really
done.
There's that,
but there's also this wiring.
There's a swath of racist out there and see some more.
Man,
I can't say that enough.
That a silly thing to be.
I have friends who are movements that hasn't really needs in a way that I
thought it would.
Well,
you can't,
you can't really bring it out because there's a lot of people in this country
that are religious and if you start making fun of religion,
you're going to lose a big giant chunk of them.
No one is saying,
ladies and gentlemen,
there is no god.
I am the last person to say there's no god.
You know why?
Because I haven't died and because I've experienced so I've experienced some
things in this life that are completely unexplainable.
I,
I'm not sure that reality makes any sense.
I'm not sure that it is a,
it's just reality is just like something you can touch and feel.
I have a feeling there's many more layers to this that we're not perceiving.
There could easily be something like a God.
But I'll tell you what's not real Mormonism.
There's not real that a fucking kid in 1820 who was 14 years old kid named
Joseph Smith found golden tablets that contained the loss work of Jesus and that
only he could read them because he had a magic rock and ex con by the way,
that yeah,
but both down at 14 he wasn't at 14 was just,
he was just a con man.
He became an ex con and a polygamous by the way.
They fucking took over Europe cause he wanted to bang multiple bitches.
He didn't want to be married to one broad.
The idea that you think that that guy had it all wrapped up,
that he was the messiah,
that he was the prophet.
You're a fucking idiot.
Okay.
That's a Dr Seuss book.
It's not even a good doctor Seuss book.
He found a magic rocks so he could read the tablets.
That's nonsense.
So if you're saying that you are a nonsense person,
no,
you can't be the president.
It least like Christianity and least Islam.
And it's,
we don't know the people who wrote them.
This is old,
old,
old shit.
When things get over a thousand years old,
it gets super blurry as to who really wrote it.
But we know the guy who wrote the book of Mormon,
we know the fucking guy.
You couldn't read the Wiki and see how it all got started because Jay balls 17
lays it out.
Did you know that it was,
they believe that there is another planet.
And then the Osmond brothers had an album based on this planet and was a call.
What was the,
what is the fucking planet?
The Mormon plan.
CLEP tar.
Oh,
something ridiculous.
Mormon Planet Osmund album.
And you know when I say this,
you know,
people say,
who the fuck you fucking eviews fucking this ain't I?
I am not an atheist.
I'm not an atheist,
but I am not a believer in bullshit.
And it's a weird thing to me that in this day and age,
you can look at something that obvious and people resist the idea that that's
bullshit.
You resist the idea that,
did Jesus really come back from the dead?
You really,
I'm not saying Jesus didn't exist.
I don't fucking know that Jesus existed,
but I guarantee you he didn't fucking just die and magically come back to life
and it's written down and because some crazy fucks that wrote a bunch of other
questionable shit down that clearly thought that slavery was okay.
Clearly treated women as second class citizens clearly said that you should
fucking be killed if you were at two different types of cloths at the same time.
I mean there's so much a looney tunes shit with that book,
but you can't live your life based on it at the Mormons figured out the loophole
for banging multiple wives at the same time.
You got to hand them that.
And I could see why someone would subscribe to that.
The planet is called call up k.
Yeah,
k.
O l.
O.
B.
And the Osmond's uh,
have uh,
in their,
their album.
Well they have one album called Kolbe and if you pull,
pull up the image of it,
Brian Osman Brothers,
k o l.
O.
B.
It's really weird cause they have like pictures drawn inside the planet of what
it would look like.
Artist renderings.
I met Donny Osmond and Donny Yasmine.
I did his show a couple times.
I did the Donny and Marie show with the news radio cast and I did it by myself
once.
And uh,
Donny Osmond is a very nice guy,
but uh,
I showed him some pictures of uh,
some,
I think some girl pulled her tits out at the comedy store.
Oh no,
that's not what it was.
It was a black hooker when I was filming.
That's filming fear factor.
I took this picture of this,
this black hooker who was walking down the street and the sandwich is like the
great Sasquatch photo from,
you know,
like from the,
the Patterson Gimlin footage and get much footage.
It's literally injured by a telephone pole and she's eating the greatest,
it's the greatest photo.
I don't even know if it can be found online.
If you can be,
if you can find it online.
Google Hooker,
I cheeseburger.
Is it online?
No,
she was eating,
I'm a meatball sub and she pulled her tit out and she's got a meatball sub in
her hands.
She's got a blonde wig.
She,
and she pulled her tits out for me.
Well,
she was a hooker,
you know,
she was trying to draw with and viral for subway.
I think she just didn't,
she lost her status.
She was just there.
It was real.
It was the universe smiled upon.
So you show it to show this to Donny and I go check this shit out.
I got this fucking picture today on the set.
And Donny Osmond looked at me like I just ate his cat in front of them.
He looked at me like I just gave him poison,
shattered his world.
We ruined his chances at heaven.
I wish we were recording.
Guy was shocked.
I mean,
he was legitimately shocked and I thought about,
I was like,
how was this guy gotten through show business and I've met like Bret Michaels.
He was a very nice guy.
I met Tom Sides,
but I've met some real freaks,
you know,
and they were very nice guys that,
I've gotten to this high level of show business.
I'm like,
how is this guy like?
So weird.
How was he so weird like he does?
Has He taught by policy?
Has He seen cake farts are two girls.
One Cup?
I don't because that seems to be a mission.
He's a super,
we need to get to front Norman.
Great.
We need to get it in front of them and record that reaction.
Listened to him a Marie like order him around.
What's just magical?
It's your photo.
That's it.
That's a real photo.
You can't,
yes you can.
Oh,
because it Ustream really elicits a woman's breasts.
Let's take a chance.
Scroll it up real quick.
It's a real woman look at that.
Got flashed by the flower.
A woman.
The breasts was,
it'd be,
it was perfect.
It was this thick.
It's like draped over the hand.
It's literally like those photos on the moon where they're standing in a
spotlight where they're like this.
No Way.
This could have actually been like set up that he that perfectly and it was a
stupid ass camera too.
It was a shitty like Motorola flip phone because it's not even like a one
megawatt hours,
I don't think.
I mean I think it was maybe one meg might have been a megapixel but it just was
the perfect photo.
That lighting was perfect.
I love that picture.
I love that truth that there is a god smiled favorably upon you and gave you
that moment.
Yes.
Beautiful feel like I feel like there's something to that and perfectly lit and
it was my background image on my computer,
but every time I would open it up on a plane and get fucking shitty looks
beautiful.
I had,
I had tried to like put folders in front of her tit but to come up people would
still get mad at me.
Icons on the private.
Yeah.
I tried to put them in there that people would still like,
Whoa,
really?
I still leave landmines in my phone,
like in my photo and my it just in the photo roll because every now and then
someone might pick up a phone or if I'm on a set,
I want to make sure the wallpaper is interesting in case the phone goes off,
so someone seeds,
he's like just dudes fisting each other,
something brilliant and they always kind of look at,
oh,
your phone,
you've got to tea.
And he never finished when I got you got to,
Oh,
oh yeah.
My favorite thing in the world.
He's just thinking like this is the guy who calls him and then he sees the
picture of guys fisting when this guy calls.
But no,
it's every call.
It's a,
yeah,
it's the default wallpaper.
I want them and there was a while where where it was a Photoshop of me getting
fucked by Ryan Seacrest's,
which someone had made for me and put it on a cake
to celebrate me going on the news.
That's a brilliant photos.
That is one of my favorite things though about the iPhone is that big ass
picture that comes up when someone calls.
I think that is amazing that that to me is like very futuristic.
Like a few call me and I looked at my phone,
I see your face.
I'm like,
wow,
that's kinda crazy.
Better than fucking trips.
Like facetime is getting there,
but the ability to click and it's them video calling you.
That's,
that's where it's at.
That's fine.
Call up yet.
Yeah.
You got to see it's fucking nonsense.
I think that the,
it might be called the plan.
Yeah.
Their album is called the plan.
I might not be call up.
It might be causing an album songs about Mormonism to,
is it like it's all,
it's all in there.
They talk about the crazy,
you know shit that they believe it.
I mean it's like it's a,
it's one of the nuttiest energy to see book of Mormon and I should see it.
It's also one of those religions where they are involved in the most arrests for
like having cults and fucking kids.
Like whenever,
like some polygamy guy gets busted it.
First of all,
it could just be that they're setting him up with the kid fucking thing,
but that's how they get them.
You know,
that they can't,
you know,
like the polygamy thing.
Well,
who can resist?
Well now they're also,
you know,
vice.com has been doing a whole series on where Mitt Romney came from that Mitt
Romney came from,
um,
religious sect of America,
uh,
American Mormons that move to Mexico so they could still bang multiple wives
because polygamy became outlawed.
They were like,
well fuck you.
We'll just move over here.
So now they're involved in like armed war with the cartels.
So it's the cartels versus the Romney's in Mexico.
Like there's drug wars going on,
the kidnapping,
them Romney's had been kidnapped,
other people had been kidnapped.
It's fucking carets has more money.
The cartels are the Romney's.
That's the quick cartels and the cartels by a long shot.
They have gold.
Everything.
Those guys make gold toothbrushes,
gold guns.
If you're seeing like how these guys go.
Jet Skis.
Yeah.
When they killed them and they find all the shit gold pistols.
And you got any photos?
I just pulled it up in three seconds.
You fuck mom,
are you using bang,
Bang it just more mass planet Osman album.
Dogpile the Cup Mormon Planet Osman Album Load Alta.
And it's the first Google image.
It's this is,
it's called the plan.
And if you,
uh,
look in it,
the other Google images,
there's one where it's got God's hand that's holding the planet.
It's,
it's so busy.
He has the whole world in his hands.
Yes.
It's so,
yeah,
look at that.
No,
that's not it.
That's not what I want to know who that guy is.
I liked that he bore his,
the Holbrook.
Mormon Planet Osmo.
Yes.
That's the,
that's the album.
If I'm the
plan and if you look deep inside the album,
it's you,
uh,
try album art.
You ever go?
Is there a Google image search?
Google it.
Just do a Google image search.
If you,
um,
I can ask Siri more.
What do you,
how many things you have grew up Mormon Planet Osmund album.
What do you have a warming planet odds.
My brother's playing the plan yet.
You can get all that other stuff out.
Come on now.
Yeah,
there it is.
See that is a,
that's the God holding the hand.
There he is holding the,
uh,
the planet that's call up.
He's just got a script that's the planet where like,
I guess God limbs or something like,
it's like such a shitty rhyme or,
uh,
such a shitty story.
It should be a rhyme.
Should be a doctor Seuss rhyme.
A kid who finds tablets,
you know,
they came looking for the tablets of where are these tablets?
He said angels came and took them away.
That was his answer.
I like that.
You shitbag fuck bad story.
Right?
And it's live journal quality writing,
but it's not even,
it's my journals.
Little better than that.
Back in 1820,
you couldn't,
you didn't have to show your sources,
know.
You'd have to cite anything in this,
uh,
this fucking guy who,
who wrote this stuff.
I mean,
does that,
this just Joseph Smith character that,
I mean,
it's,
it's a painfully bad story.
I just,
it and none of it.
It's tough that it,
it plays a role,
a role at all in society and politics.
It's,
it's insane.
It's insane.
The satisfied.
I'm not saying,
again,
I'm not saying I have any answers.
I certainly don't have any answers.
But I am saying that as human beings,
you know,
forget about religious freedom,
freedom.
At a certain point in time you have to have the ability to rationally express
what the fuck is going on.
And when you take into consideration a guys qualifications to be a leader,
one of them has to be,
whether he not,
he's up gullible.
Fuck.
Well,
it's really that simple.
You have freedom of expression when it comes to religion and that it's fine and
great believer that you want.
But when your religious beliefs influence policy,
which affects my freedom,
well suddenly I don't have religious freedom because I don't believe in the
crazy shit or what I deem to be,
you know,
not crazy.
And now your religion is informing my life.
It's determining what I can and can't.
It's a very good point.
And it's also that religion like in,
in choosing to believe something,
especially something as ridiculous as Mormonism,
that in choosing to believe in it,
it's sort of defines you as a person.
And I'm allowed to judge you in that sense.
If you're trying to run for a position of leadership,
I have to look at you as a potential leader.
There are a lot of people that I respect deeply in this world for their
intellect,
for their mind.
But I've,
I've had some people that I even really deeply respect and they have these
really big hiccups when it comes to religion and it comes to,
and when that happens,
that part of,
I know you,
I can't have that conversation with you anymore because you've got a wall up.
You've got this isn't,
you got an illogical spot.
You've got to like a little,
a little mine cancer in there.
Well,
you can't,
just,
you can't rationalize.
I remember having a conversation with a school teacher and it was a really smart
guy.
He was an interesting guy and he said,
um,
there was,
uh,
someone said something about God and about how there is no other way.
I forget what it was.
And,
uh,
and uh,
I said,
so you seen evidence of,
of stuff that that shows there's no other way that something could have existed
except for a god.
And he goes,
yes,
as a matter of fact,
molecules have been shown to be so complex.
It would be impossible for us to even imagine that let alone create them.
That alone has to be proof of a god.
And the guy was like,
yes,
it must be in the other.
The woman was like,
it has to be proof of God.
I was like,
that is the craziest thing I've ever heard.
That means that a molecule to you is the proof of the God,
not the fucking universe.
The universe,
which is composed of molecules by the way,
that are all touching each other.
And by the way,
are all nothing filled with air.
A thousand years ago we didn't know there were molecules.
So it's preposterous to go,
you will,
this is too complex.
We'll never saw this.
We didn't even know you didn't have a usage for that word or knowledge of what
it was until science discovered,
oh,
there are these little things.
And clearly we have light years to go,
but,
but this guy,
this was what he was holding onto and I was like,
I was like,
you're a steer a tea.
this guy's a teacher is a school teacher and he was a smart guy.
I was like,
I go,
Whoa,
come on man with,
there's no other way.
You know?
I'm not saying there's No God,
but your,
your argument is that something is super complex so only God could have created
it.
I was like,
you shut off.
You've a part of your head that doesn't work.
You don't use it.
My,
my mother,
despite being presented mountains of evidence that I was putting it in front of
her eyes,
really believe that John Edwards could talk to the dead,
like wanting to go on,
crossing over,
really wanted to meet him,
wanted to have him like believed in it,
not the presidential candidate,
the TV personality who claimed that he could speak to dead people and scammed
fat,
countless thousands of people out of their money by saying he,
he would do cold readings.
Basically.
I'm getting something with a j,
he would do that.
And I showed her the technique.
There were books on it.
I showed where he was trained at all that stuff.
Despite that she refused.
She had that wall she wanted to believe cause she needed to believe.
And at some point if she were president,
that may inform her decisions.
She might believe that those people exist.
She might go to them for foreign policy advice.
Like Lord knows how that would influence things.
Yes,
for sure.
If you're a gullible person should not want to keep talking and I flag on the
play and
see me.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I could drink coffee right down.
Open this door.
It's the last door on your left.
Me.
I drink coffee.
I can handle it.
I can keep it together.
You know my,
my broadcast partner in the UFC feeling sexy now.
Thank you the way better.
Um,
my broadcast partner in the UFC,
Mike Goldberg,
who I love to death,
has the smallest bladder of any human being on the planet.
It's so bad that we count me and the sound guys,
we have a running count and sometimes we'll have like a pool.
I,
I'll say like it will be over five or over six.
He will get up six times during the broadcast to pee.
I mean literally he'll get up,
he'll pee and then we'll run out in a p again.
It's crazy.
I have video of him in Vegas getting up and being,
getting no getting mad when I said,
why do you pee so much?
And then he like you tell Rogan
he gets mad because I bring it up because a,
I was playing a drinking game for a while.
I stopped playing the drinking games cause they didn't want people to torture
him with the drink game was every time he would go get up I would be the guy who
was introducing the fighters as they would walk through.
It's usually the way it sets up is Mike Goldberg.
We'll introduce a fighter and as the guys walking into the octagon,
it's a couple minutes.
So Mike will say the guy's name,
he'll maybe say some pertinent facts about the guy.
And I will address his strengths as an athlete.
I was addressed his style and what recently is coming off of and what I think he
needs to do here tonight.
And so that people have something to think about when the guy steps into the
octagon.
They don't just know the guy's name,
they also know a little bit about the guy.
But when you only hear me talking and I'm like,
you know,
uh,
Alan,
the talent Belcher ounce fight now to do groups as if it's just me talking.
That means Goldberg's Pison and I was saying,
are you throwing crickets in there?
And just saying this is boring.
That's like you only you are talking in Mike's gone worse.
That women,
that's not the use of crickets.
It's a roaring arena.
There's no crickets.
Why is he leaving?
He's leaving.
There's a cricket all of a sudden that this illogical son.
So he runs off and uh,
I say what she playing the UFC drinking game time to take a drink,
ladies and gentlemen.
And that just,
uh,
you know,
I think that tortured them.
I think too many people went after him.
By the way,
you're in North Carolina,
still available.
So go to where Joe Rogan.
Dot.
Yeah.
You can go to Joe rogan.net and all the information is also available on my
Twitter.
If you go to my Twitter page,
which is twitter.com forward slash Joe Rogan,
I'm in Raleigh,
uh,
on Friday night at the Memorial Hall and an I'm an Asheville on Saturday night
at Thomas Wolfe.
I've been a Raleigh.
I love Raleigh.
I gotta Holla at my boy cliffy be cliff it be from epic games.
Cliffy lives in Raleigh that fucking Saturday coming on the show.
Just how I got,
I got,
I got a contact email.
Contact John.
Is He guesting a show of yours?
That's awesome.
Um,
yeah,
like coming on,
like to do with a thing,
like a lot of podcasts.
No,
I don't do slide podcasts.
I think live podcasts are a rip off.
I'm sorry for all those people out there that are doing live podcasts that are
making money doing it.
But you're charging money to pay for people to sit down and watch something
that's not as entertaining as standup comedy in a comedy club.
That's how I feel.
I respect that.
I disagree with it.
What do you say it is?
I think that it's,
it's a live performance and like when I did lead up,
we made sure to make it interactive and to get people on stage and make them
part of it so it gives them an experience that they can't have the whole
festival about it.
Let me just explain something from a point of view of a standup comedian.
When I'm on stage and the crowd is,
it's a packed crowd.
There's 300 people.
I know.
What's the best thing I can do?
The best thing I can do is not sit down and have a conversation.
The best thing I can do is stand up and if there was a crowd here while we were
doing this,
if there was 300 people watching this,
I would not be able to have the same sort of conversational tone.
I would be hyper aware that
all these people are watching and how fucking boring this is to show that.
So you're paying 380 that on to me.
How dare you.
You just got fucking heavy.
We get an email.
Say it's a whole new fucking world like there was,
I couldn't,
I was trying to actively listen for like the last 20 minutes and I couldn't and
I couldn't figure out why and it's because I had to Piss so bad and it reminds
me,
there's a study that says that if you are driving with an intense need to
urinate,
it's about as bad as driving drunk.
Like your,
your ability to focus and your reaction times are so impaired because your body
is like empty your fucking bladder.
Oh I believe that.
I was going through that and I didn't realize it so I apologize.
But I'm here now.
It's a new day.
You handled it like a champ.
I was powering through man.
It was getting bad.
See I would definitely drop commercials cause old dudes want to piss a lot.
It's also why they invented adult diapers.
Yeah,
Brian use those once.
Well,
people in Times Square use them for New Year's eve and everybody knew.
Yeah,
I was there for new years and I was not interested in watching the ball drop,
but everybody was talking about,
it was like get there at six or 8:00 AM because you won't get near enough to see
anything or experience anything and you're going have to stand there all day.
And I'm like,
well what do you do if you got to go to the bathroom?
Like,
oh,
you have to wear diapers.
Everybody does.
Which has now changed my vision of any imagery in times square because the
people that are up front and you're the ball drop,
they'd been waiting since ADM and they have shit and piss in their drawer and it
doesn't help the smell.
My problem was that it smelled like shit everywhere.
Yes sir.
It's not like the mountains and Werther's originals.
No,
no,
no.
Not Times Square.
He's shit.
No.
When he shit his pants,
it smelled like shit to a grocery store.
He shit his pants.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah,
you can't hear you.
But isn't that weird like next time you see the people celebrating in the
streets at times square,
just know that a good percentage of them have a load in their drawers and they
are bringing in the new year.
Is that,
that is so ridiculous.
Is that same thing that is like commonly known,
like they know how to do hair.
Is there a forum where they meet and they say what kind of depends do you like?
Dusty landed in for smell protection.
They're like Disneyland Trin pin traders talking about strategies.
What do you do if you pick up a hot girl and you make out at midnight,
like you just meet and then at the stroke you just start making it and you're
both wearing diapers.
You got to do it.
You got to do a diaper swap because if they have to start 69 pull hers off yours
and then you bring it around and so that way you're bring her of them.
It's like back and forth forever,
man.
Get a hot doc.
Oh,
someone ate hot peanuts.
Meanwhile,
someone would be into that for someone that would be like,
there's definite community for that.
Fuck yeah.
There's a lot of people that want it.
Like Johnny balls.
17 is doing it right now on a free cam show.
[inaudible] seven.
Yeah.
It's if you could find people that want to get fucked by horses,
you can find people that want that video when you your shit,
when you hear the point where the horses,
yeah,
you hear that ground,
you know like,
oh that's the last sound you're going to be making for the rest of your life.
Like that is it.
Now I want that to be my new texts.
I want to hear that.
Whenever someone texted me,
I wonder what the numbers are of people that have been fucked to death by like
big animals like horses and shit.
Cause it's not just that one guy had enough.
Not
Enough.
I was in traffic for an hour today.
More people need to get fucked to death.
Yeah.
What are the numbers?
I wonder if so can we look at other than and Google that throughout history
would think more than a thousand.
How many people do you think
are the numbers decreasing or are they increasing?
Cause I feel like it's increasing because the population is increasing,
but also there wasn't Twitter back then.
So what else are we going to do?
You've got to get fucked by a horse.
How many people,
nothing else to do.
Influenced by the ability to put video of them getting fucked by an animal
online.
Why?
No,
that makes them pull the trigger facing camera on this thing has me doing more
than walking my neighbor's dog.
Absolutely.
It was a conversation that we had yesterday about convincing people to do things
that in the FBI,
in,
in trapping people is causing more chrome just in order to be able to solve it.
You know?
And that that's another sign of sickness in this crazy world that you can
actually talk somebody into doing something fucked up.
It's,
it's,
it's an endemic thing because of the bottom line.
They have to justify their jobs and show that they're preventing terrorism and
the only way to do that and a lot of these cases does it go out and attract
people and create scenarios that they can jump on board with and the people that
are doing it are people that are awesome at going undercover and pretending to
be someone else.
So they're getting a rush out of that too,
by the way.
A pulling it off.
Yeah.
Well sometimes those are the type of charismatic people that can talk you into
doing things.
You wouldn't have ordered it.
Right.
Done.
Well sometimes that's the case.
Sometimes they're taking ex cons and they're taking people that would normally
be stool lees and empowering them and saying,
you go do all the illegal shit you want to do and we'll back you with the badge.
We talked about all this yesterday,
unfortunately went over it with my friend tape.
We were talking about Whitey Bolger and all the different,
you know there's the guy who was working for the FBI was the head of the Boston
mob.
Yeah.
It's a mess.
It's the system.
The system is fucking completely ridiculous when it comes.
So do you think they feds are running stings where they're encouraging people to
fuck horses or get fucked the courses?
It could be they that is possible.
I think someone could,
I have a joke where did the right kind of petting zoos.
I had a joke in my last special about Mormons that Mormons are afraid of gay
marriage and if anybody should be afraid of gay marriage that it's Mormons.
Cause if someone could talk you into being a Mormon,
they could probably talk in the suck and their deck and it really is true.
Like you should be scared.
You should be scared.
Someone talk you into something completely ridiculous.
Someone can talk people into,
there's a lot of people out there that are like super persuasive and they can
talk to people and doing a lot of things.
And so when someone does something and they do it with the aid of someone who
happens to be an agent,
I used to think that that was bullshit.
That person's a criminal.
Someone came on.
If someone came along to me and told me to blow up the capital building,
I'm going to do it,
but I'm not an idiot.
There's some people out there,
they're idiots and it's not fair that somebody can come along and convince this
idiot that you know he is going to defend Islam by giving him a Bot.
Like the guy in Dallas where their taps providing them with a fake bomb.
He pressed the button and then they moved in on him and arrested him.
They gave him a fake,
but I gave him the bomb.
They gave him cab fare and it gave him everything he needed to do it.
And by the way,
there are people listening to this right now that are wearing queue re
balanced bracelets because they believe it gives them the power to lift cars and
balanced better.
So if people can be convinced to spend,
I believe that.
Do they really believe it or do they know that they're showing that?
I had a guy,
it's just power placebo.
This guy tried to do that to me,
not to this guy who was a salesman.
Mike Goldberg was telling me how great they were.
He was wearing one.
This guy was going,
he got to wear this.
This guy just going to show you.
So he brings this guy over and this guy tries some fucking Carney tricks on me.
Right?
Like putting this down on your hands behind you,
clasp your hands.
I'm gonna push down on him.
Look,
you talked it over.
Those now put the,
I go,
what are you doing?
you're not doing it the same way.
I go,
you're the,
your angle is different.
I go,
stand right here.
now do it.
I go,
yeah man,
what are you doing?
And I go,
and then I looked at the other guy.
Well,
what are you guys doing?
I,
you're playing little Carney tricks.
I go,
if you want to do something,
let's do it exactly the same way.
I go,
put my arm down now and he couldn't pull my arm down.
come on,
pull my arm down now.
Hold on,
hold on.
I got another bracelet.
Yeah,
I go,
no,
not try to do it.
I go,
you crazy who help bought this and Mike,
how is anybody buying that people but like you're moving around and showing me
different angles.
I I do Jujitsu.
I understand that there's leverage,
you're changing the leverage points and people didn't even get that though.
Some people got convinced by an infomercial in two ways.
Some people fuck that.
Some people got convinced by this guy.
I was watching people agree with him like yeah I do have more balance and I
threw a fucking wet diaper into the party.
I was like,
what the fuck are you talking to?
And he was going to get the company bonus trip to Cabo and you ruined his
numbers.
This guy grabbed my hand and like pinned it like to my body and like was like
playing mercy with me and like lifting my now try to resist.
I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You really well this is some silly shit.
If you wanted to prove that it would give you better strength,
you would make me lift weights.
You would say lift weights.
Now that you have this Brent,
why don't you feel stronger?
You know,
come on silly bitch.
So if people can be talked into that shit,
that shit will can be talked into it as an excuse to wear jewelry.
I think there's no,
it's really not that fat that's fashionable as a Christ still sleep people.
It's all,
I see it all the time.
But what it is,
is,
is a psychological tool.
There's something that it's a placebo.
Yes.
But in that respect,
for some reason it seems to work,
you know,
with,
with athletes,
even there was a measurable difference even in people that thought that it was a
placebo.
Even in people that went in with a preconceived notion that it was a placebo,
knowing that they're probably right,
still had a benefit of it because they were trying to convince themselves that
it works.
The
blood pressure placebo trial the last time I was here?
No,
it was uh,
you might want to be,
it's worth,
it's worth googling the,
I'll give you the fuzzy cliffnotes of it,
but basically they did a study where they gave people a placebo and told them
that it was a re real peel that was a real pill.
You can lower their heart rate and their blood pressure and work miracles,
miracles for them.
Then they get another group,
the same pill if it's a sugar water pill and they said this is a placebo,
this pill does nothing,
but we're doing this study to see if it will lower your blood pressure.
It did.
It did lower it in the people that even were told it was a placebo and when the,
when the trial ended,
they,
okay,
that's it.
Thank you.
The people revolted and they said,
what are you doing?
My,
my blood pressure is going to go back up.
I need this pill.
And they're like,
no,
no.
It's a placebo.
It does nothing.
The pill does nothing.
And they had to start manufacturing placebo pills.
This is the same.
You give me a detailed,
this is the exact same story.
I just simplified it.
You made it much more clear that that is,
there's some weird with our brains,
there's something weird with our brains when we believe things because I think
that reality is more malleable than we think it is.
You know that we've,
we've,
we've shown that there's certain,
there's a certain amount of effect,
positive energy and mood can have on people and there's a certain amount of
effect.
True belief in something can have on your environment.
There's something weird going on with the mind that it's not quite as simple as
we'd like to think it is.
It's not one plus one equals two.
It's one plus one equals two.
But if you believe in magic,
it might equal five,
right?
You can have,
you can have a magic variable in your equation that you change the outcome of
the algorithm.
There's,
there's belief in yourself as a strange thing.
Belief in things is,
that's why I tell people don't believe in yourself.
Well,
don't believe it.
Don't believe in anything or anyone and you know,
but no,
because if you believe in things,
it can empower you.
That's what's really fucked up.
Positive energy begets where does positive on a simple as positive energy
though.
It's not like that sort of some hippy idea,
isn't it?
What's the difference?
Just thinking positive.
It's not just thinking positive.
It's thinking specifically about certain results and thinking,
but it's thinking and be me in that direction.
Certainly you can just sit there and wish.
Yeah,
but I'm saying that there's some sort of a magical combination that when when
used is greater than the sum of its parts and that there's something to the
human mind that affects reality in a way that I don't think we've totally
measured yet.
I think that,
I think there's,
there's,
you know,
there've been studies that show that people that undergo surgery where there's a
certain rehab time,
if they believe in the power of prayer,
they tend to heal quicker and fuller faster.
And so there is clearly,
there's some quantifiable evidence,
so you should believe in something,
you know,
even believing in something that's bullshit.
Like if it empowers you,
there's something weird about that.
You should be wearing a queue right now.
Rubber bracelets for some weird people.
It's what they needed.
It's that that trigger that they needed to fire up that certain part of their
brain that gives you the green light to expect certain results.
They needed a tote.
Him like,
I can't believe that just the power of thought will be enough to compel me into
a positive or propelled me into a positive direction,
but you give me a rubber trinket that I can now attach that positivity to and I
go,
I believe that because that's a thing that has a,
an alloy is something with crystal.
It's some things.
It was a mine gets the green light.
Right.
You know what?
I realize that there's some,
when I was a kid,
when I was competing in taekwondo,
when I was 19 years old,
I went to watch
the World Cup.
Like I had a run from the time when I was 17 till I was 21 I won the
Massachusetts state championship every year and then one year I won the US Open.
I came in second in the U S Cup.
I was like a really highly ranked nationally.
And that year was the year that I went to watch the World Cup because I went to
Colorado Springs and I saw it,
the best fighters in the world.
And I came back from just watching it and all the sudden I was like a year
better.
It was like I had made this huge leap and I had a friend of mine who was a,
who is,
he's name is junk,
sick junk,
sick Chang was a kid,
was a fucking,
it was a maniac.
This guy was a,
uh,
a student who was a medical student.
He was going through his internship and training to be on the US Olympic
taekwondo team at the same time.
He was a fucking savage,
just the most hardest working kid I've ever met in my life.
I slept three hours every night,
which train like a fucking mad man.
Um,
but we were talking about it.
He goes,
what happened?
Goes,
what?
How'd you get so good?
What happened?
And I'm like,
I don't know.
I went to this one place and I hit this new level.
It's like I was like this really good local guy and then I went and I watched
the world championships or the world cup rather,
and then all of a sudden I was like,
world class,
you know,
it was,
it happened like overnight.
It happens so quick.
It was,
it was,
I realized what was possible.
I saw those guys move and I went,
oh,
you can move faster,
you could do this more,
you could do that more and but just by having a new model in my mind,
my physical body caught up to that model.
Like almost instantly.
It was like I had already had the physical capability,
but I hadn't seen it yet.
So I didn't know where my ma,
you know,
I didn't know what was possible until it was shown to me.
Yeah.
You had a barrier based off your body and then you saw,
you saw that did that,
that bar can be raised when,
okay,
I'll just go up there now.
I also saw that those guys would fuck me up.
I,
you know,
when you,
when you watch things objective,
Lee,
if you're a competitor,
the most important part of getting better is you got to know how bad you are
right now.
You've got to know what you suck at.
You got to know where your holes are.
You got to know what mistakes you make.
And if you don't see that,
the enemy can see that.
I can see that in other people immediately.
And I'm like,
man,
if I can't see that in myself,
that's a fucking horrible,
horrible handicap.
So you look at these guys and I went and washed his guys.
Remember?
Like going,
this guy would fuck me up.
This guy would fuck me up.
That guy would knock me out.
I was like,
this guy wouldn't want to fight with them.
Shit.
And I just realized that there is a whole,
so all of a sudden I was doing things that I could never do before.
And I remember thinking like,
what was holding me back?
Was it just that I hadn't seen it?
And then I remember the thing about the four minute mile,
nobody thought we could ever,
a human being could ever run faster than a four minute mile.
It's just,
it wasn't beyond our capabilities.
Then one guy did it and then all of a sudden a gang of people did it like
immediately.
It's like all of a sudden these new levels get set and new barriers get broken.
There's,
there's something to it that's not just physical.
There's something to it where the,
the belief and the,
the,
when the mind has new information,
it changes the reality.
So where do you draw the line in?
If you say [inaudible],
if you can say,
all right,
someone who has this belief for someone who has these thoughts that that
empowers them and it's positive for them.
When do you go,
well,
but your belief is wrong.
You know,
the,
the one that you have that empowers you and,
and,
and propels you in positive directions that you,
you know,
that you give credit to for the positivity in your life.
When do you go?
Okay,
well that's wrong though,
because I could question it doesn't exist or because I can prove that it was
made up by somebody,
you know,
at what point then you have the right to say that.
Is that someone else's belief?
You don't,
well a lot of people look,
you know,
whether it's the flying spaghetti monster or whether it's uh,
the Mormonism,
the Morrisons your entity or,
or a Camry,
a bracelet.
Yeah.
There's something that is empowering about having belief.
And I've seen people,
one of the things I was scared of when I was a kid and I was competing,
I was so scared is competing against religious guys.
Cause I,
I felt like they believe something more than I did have a god.
I was wondering.
Yeah,
I was filled with doubt about,
about,
you know,
I was an idiot first of all.
And I was filled with doubt about,
you know,
what would happen when I die,
my mortality,
whether I'm a good person or not.
And I would meet people that were like,
when I would see guys like reading the Bible before they would fight,
it would scare the shit out of me.
And it was like one thing that really,
there's a guy named Clayton,
I think it was in his Clayton Barber,
who is one of the top level guys in,
in my division.
And he was,
uh,
he was an army guy and he was super religious.
It was like super nit scared the shit out of me.
I was terrified of him.
He wasn't even the most dangerous guy.
He's just,
to me,
he was scary because he was too religious.
It was just too creepy.
A lot of people
do,
you know,
a lot of people say that religion is what compels them to do great things.
Religion is also strong enough to come to,
to have them fly planes into buildings.
So if that,
if,
if a book and a and a philosophy can make somebody do that,
Lord knows what it can make them do to you when the ring,
when you say fly planes into buildings,
you're completely discounting what we have.
The documents that show remote control planes.
And the only way you can get a plane to make those kinds of turns,
there's too much information.
Do you believe that?
How much corruption do you believe there is in nine 11?
Um,
I don't know.
I,
but all I know is what did I do that is from,
what was the hell was that a Pandora's box?
Did I,
did I just,
yeah,
he wants to talk about farts.
That's what it means.
Don't worry.
We can talk about old garden.
There's,
there's corruption in government.
No,
no question about it.
All you need to know is there's no reason to ever tell you the exact story.
So any story that happens,
whether it's the way we killed Osama bin Ladin,
which by the way,
we've already had a difference in the story from one of the actual seals who was
onsite who killed Osama bin.
Ladin there's a difference between his story and the official story that the
government has put out.
Did you read that book?
No,
I didn't keep in.
Now when you go back into the past and look at the Pat Tillman story and you
realize that they lied about what happened to the American hero and football
star,
Pat Tillman,
who was killed by friendly fire,
who they think may have been actually because he was complaining too much about
the war.
He was a real patriot who went over there because he thought he was going to
defend us against the terrorists.
And when he got there and realized it was a massive cluster fuck and was talking
about it quite openly.
And then he gets shagged by shacked,
no Shang frack frack fracks at work.
Um,
he gets killed and they make a total lie.
Lie,
lie.
Jessica Lynch was another story.
Jessica Lynch,
who was a woman that they said they had to take out in an,
you know,
an armed insertion to remove her from,
her.
She was rescued by a,
you know,
a high level guys when she was being kidnapped,
she wasn't being kidnapped.
She was being,
she was in a hospital being treated.
The whole,
they lie,
they just lie.
And I don't think it's,
I'm not blaming soldiers.
I'm blaming the very people at the top of the command who are doing this,
who've always been doing it like this.
They did it since operation dirty trick.
You know,
when John Glenn first went into space,
if John Glenn died,
they were going to blame it on the Cubans.
They were going to concoct evidence,
and this is all been proven right?
There were concoct evidence,
they're going to blame it on the Cubans and they were going to go,
well,
look,
we've got a win win situation here.
I send this fucking guy in the orbit.
If he blows up,
we just go fuck up Cuba,
right?
And everybody's happy and called the catalyst.
It's called the way people who have ultimate control run business.
You know,
this,
this country has always been run by that.
So when something like nine one one happens and you look at all the potential
fuckery that could have taken place from the fact that people were,
um,
gambling and betting on,
uh,
airlines failing right after or right before it happened,
that there was a massive amount of money that was,
was moved around,
insurance policies taken out for building the area.
And the fact that evidence was destroyed minutes after the event to indicate
that there's a lot of room
potential fuckery.
And if you add that to what we know has happened in the past,
I throw my hands up and I go,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't really know what happened,
but I am not willing to ever stop and say that the government is on this
occasion is telling 100% of the truth that even though they haven't done it in
the past,
and even though they'd been lying about the Iran Contra scandal,
and even though they lied about virtually every fucking thing that has ever
happened overseas,
whether it's,
you know,
fucking Gulf of Tonkin,
whether it's the reason why they pulled all their battleships out of World War
II,
out of,
um,
uh,
Pearl Harbor,
we knew before it happens.
They led it,
they receive notice.
They,
we needed a catalyst to get us involved in that war.
I sold that to g Gordon Liddy.
I said,
you know,
they were saying that on the history channel.
I had g Gordon Liddy was on fear factor.
He almost won.
You just can't see at night.
It's fucking notionally sucks.
Yeah.
See,
crash his car.
He'd have to eat weird shit.
Or who's the guy who won?
He was like a fucking,
he,
he was like a really big star in,
in the like the seventies and then he became drug addict too.
It's like a,
God damn it can't remember his fucking name.
Shit.
It's like some,
a weird obscure guy,
some singer guy.
All right.
I want to say Jared Leto but it's not him.
He is not obscure.
His music is powerful.
Amazing.
His music moves mountains,
but it's like that kind of a guy but a g chord.
Liddy you know,
I had a conversation with him about it.
He's like,
oh,
I don't know.
I don't believe that's true.
But so what they're saying on the history channel history.
Yeah.
It's like they're,
they're saying that they're decoded Japanese.
Uh,
that's one of the reasons why they left certain ships and they took out like
some of the big battleships they got,
like they allowed that to happen so that we could have an excuse to get into
World War II,
which ultimately I guess it was probably a good thing and it would suck if the
Nazis actually did win.
It means is that possible that we can have like a fucking star wars type
situation where the,
you know,
with the Nazis,
like get into a position where they can have a fucking death star.
You know?
I mean,
we're building our way towards it.
We're going to,
we're going to build the death star.
We've already got flying drones
already got the drones.
We're getting there,
man.
Yeah.
They didn't even think of that.
And Star Wars,
they didn't think they'd be 30,000 drones in the air.
Why would you need people in these tie fighters and x swing?
Star wars didn't even have Google note.
They didn't even have Google on star wars.
They had to divorce.
They didn't need it,
man.
They had the force pretty the liberal.
You got the force to the force is what we were talking about.
Yeah.
The force is the belief and the ability to,
to accomplish things.
It's funny on the power of like positive thought.
It used to be one of those guys that was,
um,
and it wasn't,
I wasn't something I was consciously doing,
but in,
in my youth I was,
I would be jealous of people that had success or sometimes be angry that someone
did something creative as opposed to appreciating that and supporting them and
being genuinely excited for them.
And I had to root that out of myself and examine that and go,
where is this coming from?
And you know,
seeds of insecurity and all sorts of stuff.
And once I was able to look at it for what it was that sunlight disinfected it.
And now being genuinely excited for people that are doing awesome things and
being positive about that has fundamentally changed my life.
And I've seen that and only the last few years so fully subscribed to,
I have talked about that on this podcast many,
many,
many times.
The difference between the way I looked at things as a young man who hadn't
really accomplished much or you know,
was really insecure too.
The way I handled things now and somewhere along the line I sort of figured it
out.
Somewhere in my twenties I figured out that it was just a weakness,
but I,
I'm really self critical.
So I had pointed that out and so I would see that in other people where they
would be hating on other folks and I'd be like,
man,
you're fucking yourself.
You don't even realize you're fucking right.
So we should all be elevating ourselves,
all of us.
And uh,
you know,
that sort of became the idea of what we do with this whole crew of us that we
call the Dell squad.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
It's like we all support each other and we all like get psyched for each other.
There's no one like Ari Shaffir right now is number one on iTunes bitches.
Yeah.
And Yeah,
we talked about it yesterday on the podcast and boom,
his new CD is number one and it's fucking hilarious.
Ari's worked very hard and we,
we started taking him on the road when he was basically he was an employee at
the comedy store and he was just starting to do like real like 15 and 20 minutes
sets the many,
many,
many years ago.
So to see him now headline and like major clubs and having the number one CD on
Itunes,
it's fucking amazing.
But that pumps us all up,
you know.
And number two is Tommy said Gaura and number who's also our buddy and what is
his white girls with cornrows,
which is hilarious.
Tom Score is one of the best fucking comics in the country right now.
He's so underrated.
He is fucking hilarious from everything.
I have to check it out.
Oh my God,
he's funny.
He's,
and he's a great guy and his shit is number two.
And then Joey Diaz is like number three or number four and Joey's been number
one for months.
It's,
it's incredible.
But it,
it benefits all of us.
It pumps us all up starting a podcast your next way you fought doing,
how do we do it on Photoshop?
Dude,
going to giving it as Kevin Pereira gets shit done.
Let's do it next week.
Yes,
I see.
Yes.
I love this.
Excellent fits to the man that together at nighttime,
Kevin Pereira,
you were officially desk squad.
Now I love it.
You're in.
Is there a,
is there a tee shirt sent us a picture of you got a hug,
Brian?
It's uncomfortable after the first 30 minutes,
but instead of prolonging the whole trick,
I like them for one,
one hour.
He go through stages of emotion.
Like he'll cry for a little bit.
I don't get aroused and don't get angry.
Well,
he'll start telling stories of his youth though you will think are made up.
Yeah,
you have to do it.
We,
you know,
it's,
it's very hard for people who don't have things going on in their life to be
happy for people.
Who Do you gotta be?
You gotta use that shit is inspiration,
man.
When you see someone win an Emmy and you're like,
I need to write a script,
get up and write that fucking script.
Don't hate on the guy who created sex in the city or the woman who grade.
I don't know if those,
you know,
I don't know why I said sex and the city.
What am I living in their fucking,
I just went back and Todd,
it's a phenomenal theory.
Don't,
don't hate on Louis C K for just winning two Emmys that yeah,
it's awesome,
but love the shot of him in the crowd with the two Emmy's at his feet and he's
just tweeting.
Yeah.
I don't know if you've seen that.
It's almost like it could care less,
but you know,
but he's just,
yeah,
well,
you know,
he's,
he's the real deal and he's a hard working guy and so you should be excited
about that.
You should see that guy and you shouldn't say,
man,
he's got this going on and I can't even get a middle spot.
You know,
you gotta just gotta work,
match,
just got to work,
you know.
But you'll find it gets a lot easier to do that work and you find a lot more
support when you're not pissed at people and jealous for their success.
It makes you way better and it's easier to be creative.
The one of the hardest parts of being creative is if you're in in tension with
someone or you have issues or you're jealous or you're,
you have any sort of negativity.
It's very difficult to be creative with any sort of negativity in your life
because you know,
that becomes the blaring focus.
Instead of letting the mind relax and go into these weird sort of patterns of
thoughts that create creativity,
especially comedic create.
You can create great music because you're pissed at an ex girlfriend or you have
a heroin problem,
but it's really hard to make comedy.
I mean,
how many great songs been written by Dudes who are just trying to get a girl
back?
Probably a lot,
right?
Countless.
It's so sad.
I love that.
Then I'd also love that drugs have shaped the design and sound of music
throughout time.
Like there've been,
there's been studies that show that,
you know,
cocaine makes you more sensitive to higher frequencies and that's why a lot of
the music from the 80s had the trouble blasted way up cause dudes were just
blown out on coke at the mixing board.
Go.
Yeah,
give me that symbol.
Give me that guitar screen.
My end.
I just finished the dirt off the teacher at the Motley Crue store,
the Motley Crue tales.
Have you read that?
It's brilliant.
Really brilliant is really,
Neil Strauss wrote it.
I mean it's very well written and it tells you the prospect,
I'm not even a motley crew fan,
I barely know their music.
But the stories in here seem unbelievable that as you flip the page you'll get
the same tale.
But from another band member's perspective.
So by the third chapter you've got real perspective on incidents that happened
of like girls being stuffed into litter boxes and guys,
Oh Dang.
In the back of cars.
Oh yeah,
like crazy shit.
Blow jobs and private jets while people are overdosing.
It's just rock and roll as rock and roll gets.
Wow.
That's the program by the way.
You were taught.
Oh,
the one that stitches,
stitches.
Everything in your diet.
That's another one because that is definitely not the name of it and that's
awesome.
Yeah.
You why clothes?
There's work on all platforms.
It was an apple store.
Look at that fake iPhone that shows it.
See,
these are a bunch of people connecting.
How great is that?
That's amazing.
But that song sucks up back at deck talking about man,
so that was dope.
The fuck was that when a vista social club.
Amazing.
Speaking of songs,
everybody keeps asking me,
when is this fucking into the world party tickets going on sale.
They're going on sale this Friday and it'd be honey,
honey,
Joe Diaz,
Doug,
Stan hope and myself.
December 21st,
2012 at the Wiltern theater in La.
Come celebrate the end of the world.
Bitches.
We're going down swinging.
We're going down with mushrooms and whiskey.
That's what we're going to throw him out to the crowd,
like fusing messages.
Johnny look,
this is the a,
this is the big date that all these crazy people and Terence Mckenna had been
predicting of some real change and I don't,
I don't believe that anything real is going to happen unless maybe we make
something real happen.
You are the one,
you know,
maybe you're the reason,
but dude,
Gotcha.
God,
what is going to happen though is we're going to have a good fucking time and
Stan hope and I,
when we first talking about,
yeah,
December 21st that's the end of the Mayan calendar.
That's the,
that's the day.
The day end of the long count.
Not going to see 30 you will,
it's not going to end.
It's all going at,
no,
I don't buy it.
I think we're going to pull it out.
You know what I think,
I think there's a battle right now between idiocy and technology and I firmly
believe that things improve and without any sorts of,
if we can avoid nuclear war and cataclysmic impacts by,
you know,
asteroids and super
volcanoes,
shit along those lines.
But we also have to accept the fact that the more data comes in,
the more we realize there's certain parts of the planet that are habitable and
then become inhabitable and we have to fucking accept that and we need to start
thinking about that here in southern California when it gets 110 fucking 30 40
50 days in a row,
at a certain point in time you've got to go,
what if,
what if it gets to one 30 what if he gets the one 50 right?
What are we doing?
We're going to stay here and like wear suits on our way to the,
you know,
everywhere we go so that we stay alive
like a gray aliens sleeve.
We'll have to be buying this from an apple.
What are we going to do if the,
if,
if there really is,
this is the precursor to an ice age and what if the shift comes like in dramatic
form,
like they believe it has all throughout history,
like the end of the last ice age abruptly happened,
including massive extinction events like the wooly mammoths,
saber tooth tiger,
all sorts of animals just disappeared off the face of the earth.
And we got to accept the fact that that shit could happen here just because we
have a database of a couple of thousand years of civilization and all living in
the same continents.
We also have a fucking map of Greenland that they don't really understand where
these people,
excuse me,
not Greenland,
Antarctica.
There's a map of Antarctica that came from the 15 hundreds that is a very
detailed map of the perimeter and it's correct and they don't know who the fuck
charted this thing because,
and Arctic has been frozen for God knows how long and they the the,
the suspicion is that some point in time and Arco is actually inhabitable,
habitable.
And there's all these sites that say there's pyramids on Antarctica that they're
discovering,
but I don't know.
I don't buy that.
If it seems like fuckery,
it seems like some horse shit.
It'll yeti homes.
Yeah.
But I'm not,
I'm,
I'm completely convinced that in the course of human history,
the hundreds of thousands of years that have been things that are remotely close
to what we look like,
we've had to flee.
You know,
we've had to get the North America was covered at nice a mile high sheet of ice.
The Great Lakes are created by all of this giant boulders removed this,
this huge slab of ice comes down.
It's a mile high and it pushes slowly across the land,
literally erasing everything and its site.
You gotta get the fuck out of there,
you know?
And that,
that easily could happen to us again.
It's interesting to think like if there were another catastrophic environmental
event that wiped us out,
if,
if thousands of years go on and another human civilization and spawn and birth
like what relics they would find because they might not ever know that we
developed the Internet,
that we had iPhones that we had anything else they would get,
you know,
guns maybe,
maybe a clay pot or two,
but they would really have a knowledge of our civilization because of the way
we're storing it.
Yep.
What
the fuck?
Yeah,
they would be fucked.
There was,
yeah.
Well that's exactly what they believe happened to the people that built Baalbek
in Lebanon where they have these 10 foot tall stones are 7,100 feet long and
they don't even know why the fuck they got them there.
And they don't even know when they got them there.
They have no idea.
And that's the,
the really extreme people that believe in the,
the,
the ancient civilizations advancement,
they,
that's their,
that we lost all the glass and metal and all gets absorbed.
You know,
we,
uh,
we showed a Blendtec blender blending an iPhone.
We showed a video of that yesterday.
It's amazing.
And like what do you think would happen if that iPhone got in the bottom of a
glacier and it's a mile high and it's moving,
you know,
a foot a year or whatever the fuck it does.
Just crossing everything in front of it.
Trillions of tons of ice.
You wouldn't get much more than that either.
It would just crush it down to nothing.
You mentioned though,
you mentioned this war between like ignorance or stupidity and technology and
that's the battle that it,
it's,
it is a huge battle,
but what concerns me and I'm,
I am fundamentally an optimist,
but I always,
I always raise a flag when I can and what concerns me is technology's role in
dming people down that its role,
its role as a propaganda machine.
Astroturfing you know,
where you can make it look like the opinions of many are something just with a
click of a mouse.
There are companies that are designed to do this where you can disseminate
information.
People can live in their bumble,
bumble,
where if if let's say a Republican Google something or a Democrat googles
something,
their results are filtered and different from each other like this is happening
today.
I see that,
but I also,
and I agree with you that that is a concern,
but I also see that the free distribution of information,
ultimately we'll balance that out because I see that what's going on now is more
skepticism,
more intolerance to corruption,
more understanding of the corruption itself than it's ever existed before.
And that is because of the Internet.
Right.
But have you read Youtube comments like that?
I know I've been,
I mean as much as it,
that's a joke,
like that skepticism is being fueled,
empowered and growing exponentially on both sides of every issue.
You know what I mean?
Like the commentary and the dissection and the editing of information,
which is prevalent now.
People,
people seek out voices that,
that that's been raised thinking that they want to have.
Yeah,
that is true for now,
but I think people are better today at,
I know I am certainly better today at seeing contrary points to seeing
information that doesn't jive with me as you seek them out though.
It's because I seek them out.
But I think that's a trend that we could set and all sorts of people.
I think the only way to really truly benefit is to actually truly benefit and
the only way to truly benefit is to to be honest and real and to know what is
going on.
Not to have a distorted perception of what's going on because you can only live
in that distortion for so long before you go fucking insane.
And even people that are insane wish they weren't.
And I think there is a way that we can all figure out how to get through this
and not be insane.
And the only way is truth,
reality at an objective thinking.
I think the internet facilitates that in a way that nothing else beforehand.
I think the Internet getting,
it's only been here for a couple of decades,
I think it hasn't even had a chance to set trends in the future generations of
humanity,
which I think are inevitable.
I think what we're dealing with is the adolescents of the Internet,
the adolescence of why I always refer to today as the roaring the digital era.
Right?
And then eventually we're going to figure this out and get it locked down.
But it's going to define a huge human beings are,
it's going to define them in a way that didn't before.
The access to information from the time they were a young child and the ability
to disseminate information and you know,
and,
and double and triple check things.
And there's people like Wiki leaks and there's people like anonymous that are on
top of shit to make sure that everybody knows the truth and I think that will
spawn others.
And I think that is the trend of the future.
The trend of the future is the truth.
And I think that's all being distributed through the Internet and imaging
changing generation.
Again,
as a,
as,
as a fundamental optimist and a,
an advocate for technology.
I agree and I hope,
but with that said,
just as a,
the Internet's ability to distribute information and disseminate truth,
it's also in its infancy to distort and to deliver messages to people that are
targeted and false.
Sure.
But that requires conspiracy and the conspiracy doesn't necessarily think about
conspiracy is conspiracy doesn't necessarily empower the individual and the
individual is the one who's going to break the conspiracy much like wikileaks,
much like that Bradley Manning Guy did that,
people are going to realize that that does not benefit them too to help this big
giant group of clients,
you know,
and I think that as a trend or that giant group of cons,
we'll use astroturfing and the technology available to deliver a specific
message to them on the channels that they're getting it to that either a,
they believe it's truth or they feel like they need to believe it for their
security or for a myriad reasons.
Maybe again,
my argument is that it's going to be harder and harder to do that.
I'm just saying we need to be vigilant.
Ever vigilant.
Yes,
I agree with you.
That's why I'm starting a podcast.
Fuck death squad.
Fun next week.
Kevin Pereira stepped up to the plate kid.
Yeah.
I don't like going to talk about fisting and cake farts.
That's all you need to talk about.
It's all it really.
Everything else is redundant.
Parts is still one of my favorite videos.
It's about fun,
Ladies and gentlemen.
That's what this life is.
It's,
I mean you want to break it down too.
Hippy positive energy.
You want to break it down to that.
That is one way to look at it.
Although it's sort of an idea has been painted by yoga instructors trying to
fuck their students.
There's more to it and by you know cocacola saying that that coke will deliver a
smile if you want fun by our product as possible that some products do deliver
fun though,
right?
I do.
Have you tried oxycontin?
What about you're a seven.
Oh my God,
so much fun.
It's a Audi we're talking about.
If you look at what does the space ship on wheels heaven.
It is a spaceship.
Yeah.
Rich guys talking about cars.
That's what the folks need in this world.
That's real change.
Aspirational programming.
How dare you?
I'm sad.
I'm sad that it's just Obama and I thought when Obama came into office that we
were going to have like a real,
wasn't there a moment where you really thought like,
Holy Shit.
I thought too,
and it wasn't because I believe the campaign,
I really believe that we would see change because his first campaign was funded
by the people and you know,
again,
money and politics is the root of so many evils.
Lobbyists,
super packs,
all that shit.
It's the root of so many evils that I thought like,
here is a guy who's going to be beholden to us because we put them there.
I personally donated,
he's a young guy.
He's comes from a single mom.
He's half black.
He's been to the an elitist.
It's not some blue blood count and went to school in Connecticut,
right?
Yeah.
I thought this is,
this is our chance.
I thought this was really going to be a check and the push Cheney administration
was clearly evil.
I mean you could be a Republican all day,
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you are a fan of civil liberties,
if you are a fan of,
uh,
of people looking out for people,
have the fuck,
could you be a fan of fiscal side,
fiscal conservatism?
Like they blew up the budget.
They went unframed wars and everything else.
So pretty insane.
And that was pretty telling that they've,
none of them were at the RNC and the single one of them,
not a single one of them.
Yeah.
Erase those memories.
That hilarious.
You would think that the last sitting president,
the last Sydney president to term press a whole cabinet,
he's someone that they would bring out.
Now they're avoiding any mention of George W he might be insane by now.
Who knows?
When was the last time you saw him get interviewed?
He might be out.
He's on a ranch right now.
He's doing fine.
I think he's got to be,
there's gotta be some disconnect in order for you to be a guy who's responsible
for the death of hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of people.
There's gotta be some sort of a disconnect.
And ultimately I think that's probably what fuck Ronald Reagan's head over.
I think that it fucks up a lot of people.
That's look Johnnie Cochran and Robert Kadash in both those guys died young of
like brain tumors.
Okay.
Why?
Cause they got Oj Simpson off.
They know.
They know they did something,
some evil shit they had.
I mean you get brain tumors,
two guys get brain tumors.
They die of,
I think they both got brain tumors.
Is that the case?
But I have proven it in a quarter.
Both young.
They both died young.
I mean that's your,
your,
your health pays a fucking price for that shit.
I'm not,
I'm not saying that that's the reason why he's on that.
Like where people have to lie during a study or do something that they believe
is morally wrong and then they test their physical health to see if that
knowledge,
if those secrets weighs on them.
Cause it must,
I'm sure it has to have a load bear on your soul to it's,
it fucks people over man.
You've seen people's faces when they've gone through scandal and they're dealing
with negative and negative energy becomes real.
Talk to Jamie Kilstein,
I want to,
negative energy will fucking come down on you for real.
Has there been a study on memory call,
a memory recall and memory call of those who are documenting and experience
versus those who are actively participating in it?
Like for example,
if I'm at a concert or if I'm at any event and I'm too busy taking photos for
Instagram and tweeting about it and snapping photos and whatever,
yes,
I can look at those memories and I have recall of those memories,
but how active is my memory of that event and you know how on what scale would I
rate that experience versus being present and enjoying it?
Extremely subjective.
Depends on the individual,
depends on how they viewed the past,
whether or not they've had traumatic experiences at any sort of event before,
whether they've had a reason to look at things in great detail.
They've also shown that people can experience things and then if there's a
certain amount of time where someone introduces something that didn't actually
happen in your,
and then revisits
it with the same information later that these people will agree that something
happened that didn't happen.
So they'll intentionally inject expecially during emotionally charged events.
They'll intentionally inject some sort of a fake memory into someone's mind and
later that becomes real.
And that's what people have argued about Oj,
that Oj actually does believe that he didn't kill them after a while,
that like you might even be able to fucking pass a polygraph test after a
certain,
oh,
you can absolutely introduce false memories by asking leading questions.
You've got the guy in the white hat,
what guy?
I know the guy in the white hat.
Oh,
of course there was a guy in a white hat there because now you're asking,
well,
you know that whole story about those people that were wrongly convicted of
child molestation,
they were running a daycare center and they had talked all these kids into
coming up with stories of someone touching them and it was all full.
False.
It was all bullshit,
but they had introduced it into a child's brain.
And like there's one thing to talk about memories and how tricky that can be
because on one hand there are memories in my life that I have that I can tell
you with absolutely no uncertainty whatsoever that I remember exactly what
happened.
But there's some that I'm like,
man,
it's like,
uh,
like flash show in my head.
It's like a snapshot show.
I see like a slide here,
a slide.
And if I can
interpolate that for you and say,
well then between slide eight and slide be this event happened,
you might actually connect those dots and go,
well I guess your event did happen.
Cause I could see that being part of it
sort of end things get recalibrated to like I remember I had a particular image
of the house where I grew up in and then I went back and saw it recently and I
was like,
Oh yeah,
okay.
It was over here now.
Oh it was this way,
you know,
it was like I had to recalibrate and now I have the revised version.
I have all the,
I have everything put into place,
but if you had made me like draw my street before,
I might have fucked it up entirely.
You know,
I might've had different people's houses and the wrong sides and we're,
well the bridge is over to the left.
Fuck,
I thought it was over here.
You know,
you can,
you can twist shit up and make it real inside your stupid head.
You know?
And maybe that's,
that's one of the benefits of the upgrade when we're going to be able to video
record everything 24 seven yeah.
And people,
it's going to start out with Google goggles,
then work its way to a chip that you put in your eyeballs.
It'd be contact lens with led and then you won't even need that.
Who's going to be the first person that lets their eyes get cut out for some new
eyeballs that we've invented that are way better that's going to happen.
Reading a book about that.
Right now it's a fictional tale about a guy who loses his leg in a traumatic
accident,
but he's an engineer working at this future kind of biotech company.
So we designed a better leg and it gets addicted to the fact that his bionic leg
has better features and can do certain things that his real lay can't.
Sweet cuts off his real leg.
The other ones so we can have to bionic legs,
but then he's like,
well,
if my legs are better,
why don't I cut off my arm?
Oh my God.
It's like,
it's fucking awesome,
Jesus.
And you would think the $6 million man would not be happy with just a good right
hand.
You know,
he throws a Shitty Jab and we'll hire it comes the right hand of doom that could
punch right through your head.
There's a great of people throwing baseballs
with their non dominant hands.
I don't know if you've seen it.
It's hilarious.
Like the,
the,
the weakling little throw in the awkward motion that if you try to do anything
with your nondominant hand,
if I had a bionic arm talking about this the other day,
do you guys think you can masturbate using your nondominant hand like I,
it absolutely that masturbation is just this,
it's not a lot of works.
Weird playing pool lefthanded is really fucking hard.
I play really good rice chicken off of the cue stick though.
That's all you,
that's,
you were just doing a euro grip.
Yeah,
but it's not,
it's how you,
you,
you judge the plane of your,
your arm.
Like how it's,
it has to be,
you have to be in control of the speed of the motion and there's a lot of fine
motor skill movements going on.
There is nothing compared to drawing.
I can,
I can shoot pool,
I can make certain shots with my left hand.
I can't draw with my left hand at can you write like you're going to get fucking
barely my,
it's doesn't listen.
Every guy is ambidextrous when it comes to jerking off.
Yes.
Come on.
It's every,
every guy can switch it.
I can't what?
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Like if there was nothing in front of me like,
and I had my,
my imagination with my right hand,
I could,
you know,
do it on my left hand.
I think from scratch with nothing in front of me.
I don't think I can even get it
balanced place.
I disagree.
I know you could do it.
You would just have to be horny enough.
See,
when you say from scratch,
you're talking about your regular life,
which you beat off like a fucking spider monkey every three or four hours and
that twice.
You need a highly tuned jerk off him for that kind of beating up.
You're a guy who watches porn all the time.
You Bang Porn Stars.
You know,
you've got a lot of ridiculousness going on and your situation that doesn't,
you know.
But if you were like a guy who couldn't ever get laid and you couldn't,
you didn't have access to porn and you weren't jerking off no flashlights and
you went without beating off for like two weeks.
And then someone said,
here,
here's a porno film beat off with your left hand.
He'd be like,
fuck
you had Peter North.
It's all over your screen.
It just seems like it's,
it seems like it's just,
it seems like it's really like a dead.
Like it doesn't feel like it has any feeling.
You got to build calluses on an on a new guitar player.
You've got to fill it up.
It's like my joke that I had like way,
way,
way back in the day about having a girl jerk you off though but having a girl
jerked you off to like trying to brush your teeth with your left hand.
It's like just clumsy spastic and that your right hand and years a mother
Fucker,
you're right hand knows where the gum line is and it gets that fast vibration
but your left hand is like you have to like hold it still and move your face
over to the brush because your hand is so stupid.
It doesn't,
it doesn't have a brush.
I baby bird with two Sonicares every night animals.
You know what?
I did want to make sure I can double fist the by put a qtip in each ear and I
took a shit at the same time and then that blacked out from ecstasy.
It's the most amazing feeling.
Cleared all your orders.
There's this wonderful feeling,
isn't it?
There's a
new toilet add on that they're selling the squatty and it's like,
uh,
it's,
it's supposed to be like a thing that it stores and on it,
no,
you sit,
but it elevates your legs so that you have more of a squatting posture,
which like relaxes the,
the tracks of the,
the shit can slide out easier.
And it's been scientifically proven that squatting,
I mean,
we've done it for years and years and years as a society until we have bowls to
sit down on that.
It's,
it's more efficient.
It's healthier for you.
There's another is Adam.
Yeah,
just look at many places,
but I don't think that's,
I wonder if that's going to catch on people shitting part about people are so
weird about fecal matter and biological movements in general.
Well when Brian and I were in Japan,
one of the things that we buy,
waste toilet guys sent me these toilets best and I got to thank this company
that sent me the toilet because I don't have the information.
Yeah,
they sent me two of them.
I haven't set them up.
Yeah,
I think the ones with the heating massaging and the ass jet.
Yes.
The whole deal.
And they will be such a joy will be at the new studio.
So Brian,
when you take a shit at the new studio and you will be able to clean,
they are,
they're called.
They're,
it's,
it's from the company's called Braun del and um,
it's B r o n d e l l.com.
And Bron Dell has a,
they sent us to have these in there.
They're fucking Cadillacs for your ass cheeks.
Everybody want to be shitting with them.
One in my,
my Home Office and one in the studio and it will be dope as fuck.
You sent a new studio.
Yeah.
I got a new studio in Woodland Hills.
Congrats.
Thanks.
It's all set up.
It's fucking Badass.
It's,
um,
the lace Lisa signed and now there's equipment being built.
Right now I'm hiring a astute Eric who created Brian's a cat clock over there.
The death squad clock.
Yeah.
He uh,
he's a metalworker.
He's building me this custom,
like this whole thing set up kind of,
and it's going to be cool because it's reclaimed wood.
We're using like reclaimed farm.
Oh yeah,
cycling.
Yeah.
Not only that,
it's,
I like the fact that it's got like some life to it.
Like it's old,
like this,
people been using this,
there's like vibes in it.
I,
you know,
I subscribe to a Rupert Sheldrake idea that even objects have of sorter.
Yeah.
Residence and a member of energy has been pumped into them.
That's what like the old recording studios,
we'd be like,
well,
these albums had been recorded there and I'm like,
that means something.
And that energy was,
was captured there.
Dude,
I'm going to take you after this podcast is over into the main room of the
comedy of the comedy room here at the Ice House.
And you tell me if you don't feel vibes in this place,
this place is fucking magic.
This,
the ice house is a perfect example of a,
like a vortex of like happiness.
There's so many people have laughed their fucking ass off in that room.
That room has a resonance.
You feel it.
Yeah.
You know,
it was really bad ass,
by the way.
Speaking of the,
uh,
Eddie Murphy and Chris Rock,
we're both at the comedy store last night.
Really
just walking in and like a,
you know,
it's just hanging on Tuesday or whatever and uh,
I'm just like,
Holy Shit.
That's Eddie Murphy.
That's crazy.
On stage.
Or they were just hanging out watching,
speaking of which,
we got to get Charlie back in here,
man.
We haven't had Charlie in here in a while.
I gotta I gotta contact them.
That was one of my favorite episodes when he's telling the story about Mike
Tyson,
they pull up the Mike Tyson towels or whatever.
Charlie Marvis nuzzling.
I'm greatest storytellers ever.
Last summer I was in Hawaii with my family on vacation and I ran it.
His cousin rich at the resort.
It's like,
what are you doing here?
Charlie's here.
Ed is here,
and I hung out with Eddie.
I had lunch with Eddie Murphy and Charlie.
It was like,
this is the weirdest thing ever for being a kid in the to watching raw and then
all of sudden I'm talking to Eddie Murphy about comedy.
I was like,
Whoa,
this is bizarre man.
We're just sitting there talking to him like this is the strangest thing ever.
He was super nice man.
I've heard Eddie Murphy could be a dick.
He couldn't have been nicer man.
He was.
Maybe he was with his family.
I mean
that was one of those things where I was,
I was always talking.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
I'm talking about Eddie Murphy.
Right?
This is legit.
When that moment happens,
do you feel yourself like projecting out of your body and getting lost in your
own thoughts or do you keep it together pretty well and go,
Oh shit,
I'm talking,
but focus up.
This is a moment.
No,
I stay in the moment.
Yeah,
there's a like a little voice.
I was like,
shut up bitch.
It's a six year old kid in cowboy,
but Callaway Pajama onesy yeah,
the kid who listened to his first CD when he was on Saturday night live,
it was a cassette back then.
His best work in my opinion,
wasn't even delirious.
It was the album before delirious where he talks about putting an aftershave on
his dick and Washington's Paula's sick and his grandma came in.
You Lazy motherfucker washing you dick in the sink.
You too lazy to even take a bath wash your fucking funny man.
This it's,
there's a weird thing.
But like when I met Anthony Bordain it was just,
it seems silly,
but it was a weird thing.
I was like,
oh,
this is a fucking,
and I'm actually talking to Anthony Bordain.
This is strange.
Like he had no reservations about it.
When you like somebody and then you meet him,
it's real weird.
And when,
so when people meet me,
me and they get weirded out,
I'll go,
dude,
I've been there.
Don't worry about it.
Just get through it.
Write it out.
Right.
We're all just,
people just takes time.
That said Kevin Smith for president.
That's why I'm voting in Kevin Smith.
Kevin Smith for Pepsi running.
No,
I'm trying to think.
I'm going to vote a man.
He's a good guy.
It seems like you would run things fairly.
Sure is running.
He started out from scratch.
He's my,
my guy,
you know,
no one's no one's to,
everyone talks about a Gary Johnson and if people even mentioned me,
I think Kevin Smith,
I say he's a good dude.
It's put on for the president.
You want to be as vice president Kevin prayer vice president really venture out
was talking about running in 2016 and I think Howard stern is his running mate.
I think that's awesome.
Howard stern is,
is writing.
Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
But then sure.
It's like what his record of everything from entertainer to book rider to
government official to navy seal.
What about tower shoveling?
Whenever bring up rose tower.
Oh good.
I was a navy seal.
I love it.
It's one step closer to President Camacho.
Um,
I think that he has a good grasp on the amount of fuckery in this government.
But if you listened to way,
hey,
a debated with Jimmy Norton when you went on the opie and Anthony show him and
Jimmy Norton and you realize he's Shitty,
but he's kind of a flush shit.
He's got some fuckhead in him.
Don't think so.
This Brian?
No,
Brian did get them on mushrooms.
Was Your Bronco a full toilet or is it one of those lids?
The Lid.
It's just like the ones in Japan.
They take your regular lid off and they put this electric tronic ass cleaning by
Flam,
a jammy warm water up your butt thing.
It's amazing USB cable that gets in there and cleaned it all out and it's
something that makes you realize like,
why are we so gross with our smearing poop paper?
Because that's all it is.
We need the three seashells.
We all need to have our asses cleaned like that.
It would probably be like way healthy this and that's one of the things they're
Muslims.
Make Fun of.
Muslims make fun of it.
Yeah.
That's when you really love a,
when you shit in front of her.
I've seen guys shit in front of the girlfriends and I was like,
I have never been that comfortable with someone in a real relationship.
Do it on her chest and plastic wrap and just get it going.
I to say alone,
I think the rumors of Stallone,
even if they were true,
it's like I've seen it all.
You want to fucking shock me shit on my job.
You have to read the third when they're putting hotel room phones in a women's
assholes and trying to order room service by yelling into them.
No,
this is in the Rock,
the Motley Crue book.
It's a great book.
Not even a fan of Motley crew,
but the shift is a datable bone and a girl.
It's on audible.
It's absolutely worth listening to.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Imagine you're the next person,
that fucking hotel room and you go to,
I can't up dessert.
I'm getting weird about hotel rooms in order.
I'm sorry.
You shouldn't be weird.
Yeah.
The remote control is like the remote control in the end,
the bedspreads,
how many sheets with the bedspread?
How many naked dudes are just beat off there and how many real controls have
been up someone's ass.
I don't have to clean this.
I'll put that there.
Right up to her ass.
Yeah.
Bent over trying to use the remote from inside your ass.
What your sphincter
while they do a Kegel,
I can watch pay per view.
The thing is still pointing outward,
right?
So you got out of the butthole with your ass to get the right numbers tend to
check out.
This fucking podcast is in the toilet,
ladies and gentlemen,
where it should literally are really,
and I don't like to say literally Kevin Smith for President folks.
Let's get this trending.
Let's make it that Kevin Smith on Twitter.
He's a good fucking dude.
He could run things over Kevin for Kevin.
Prayer and callous man,
bring the two of them together.
Dual ticket.
Let's do it.
I love him.
I'll watch from the sidelines and now we need you out there in the word.
We mean the death squads to do it through Twitter.
There we go.
I'll preach.
I'll preach through Twitter.
It's the revolution.
A occasionally youtube
and uh,
I'll uh,
I'll,
uh,
whatever we can go to Kevin Rose is sex parties will help you when you launch
your new podcast on the desk squad network next week.
Kevin Pereira.
Gentlemen,
I'm new top 10 podcasts.
I've got shit to plug it into it,
into the fucking made trucks.
We're going to change things folks
from,
from the ground floor will on its sponsor.
Me.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Done.
All right folks.
Let's fucking bring this bitch home.
Kevin.
You're an atom.
An animal,
a great human being.
Thank you.
Fucking fantastic guests.
Always a pleasure.
We always,
it was like,
we're about to run out of time on Ustream,
but it's like we could do another six hours of this shit,
right?
You have to do this morning.
Gonna do a marathon with the camp.
We're gonna well,
you're going to be,
you're gonna have your own podcast.
I'm going to do yours.
You're going to do mine.
Keep this party.
Rolin this weekend.
You fucking savages in North Carolina will be in Raleigh at Memorial Hall Friday
night,
which is what's Today,
the 26th the 28th Friday the 28th of September at Memorial Hall and Raleigh and
then Saturday night we're at the Thomas Wolfe Auditorium in Asheville,
North Carolina Asheville.
I hear that's what I hear.
That's a bad mother fucking town except for the white dudes with dreadlocks and
then drum circles.
I hear that Shit's got go.
So we need you to do is get to Asheville and introduce those kids to some
fucking squats,
deep squats and some bison meat.
Okay,
put circles.
Put The toe food down.
If you don't eat bisons they just rot or monsters common and eat them and then
we get more monsters eating bisons whatever could kill a bison.
You don't want that fucking thing around.
Okay,
trust me.
Kill the bison yourself.
Keep the population in line.
Have a good steak.
Build that testosterone.
Do Hill sprints.
I want you to do some sandbag training.
Stott decking,
Jujitsu,
my friend trying to make some army here and the only way the army really is
going to work as if they're smart.
So they got to take the Alpha brain.
Go to on a.com o n n I t get yourself some Alpha brain.
Thanks again to audible.com for sponsoring this podcast.
And if you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you can try audible three for 30 days and get a free audio book.
Um,
there's a lot of good ones.
fuck,
what was the one,
the Bobcat Goldthwait Bobcat Goldthwait is cut a couple of good books up there
too.
Brilliant motherfucker.
And he's a great guy.
We had him on the podcast and we love him and uh,
that's it.
Okay.
So we will see you next week.
We got a ton,
oh,
podcast guests next week,
including Amber Lyon,
formerly of CNN.
She's going to tell us what the fuck is going on in this crazy wacky world of
the media.
Uh,
we also have the guys from London Real and London real is a great podcast that,
uh,
has been,
um,
they've said themselves,
they were inspired by this one and that's what made them start it.
And they're doing a fucking amazing job.
They've had Graham Hancock on and Simon Powell and a bunch of really interesting
people have talked a lot about psychedelics and,
and uh,
martial arts and philosophies.
It's very,
very similar to this show and a lot of ways and really interesting
introspective,
honest dudes.
So they will be on next week as well.
And uh,
we're fucking,
we're,
we've got shit Roland bitches,
ten second plot.
I told him forgot to.
Let's ask America.
Dot.
TV.
It's a new game show that I'm doing syndicated Telepictures it's only a few
markets,
but if you guys go there,
click on the youtube link,
watch the first episode or two,
you might not like it.
I love it.
It's a fun,
silly game show.
You should fucking be on it.
I'll do it.
Yeah,
you play from home using Skype.
I'll do it.
So any of your audience can sign up.
And I've seen dudes when $50,000 in 20 minutes,
I've hosted a show and he ended up 50 grand for having an opinion about America.
Holy Shit on your Webcam.
It's amazing.
New game show.
I'm having a blast doing it.
So I just said,
what would I do?
What might be a judge or something you can do?
You can test.
It can be condensed.
I mean you probably have to play for charity,
but I played with journey's done.
Okay.
No,
pick a good charity.
You got it.
Okay.
Beautiful.
So let's ask.
Remember that TV?
Oh,
hopefully.
Yeah.
Ian Edwards back next week.
Ian's a fucking hilarious comedian.
Uh,
he should be here today,
but honestly,
Kevin Perez,
um,
but Ian's great guy.
No,
Ian's great.
Well,
he's going to check out my new pod.
You know,
it's a better guest because he's here.
That'll right.
He didn't have to fucking cancel that flight.
Bitch.
You got a flight cancelled that,
change it and move it around.
Don't cancel the podcast.
How dare you.
This millions of people listening to this shit.
This is for you.
It's disrespectful,
you know,
and I'm sorry that it happened.
It's for all of us together.
We are all in this dirty thing together.
Ladies and gentlemen,
remember if I can tell you anything,
give you any piece of advice is you can be the hero of your own story.
If your life was a movie and it started right now,
act like you're the hero.
Get Shit done.
Do what the hero would do and you will have a beautiful life.
Can I see as soon?
Next week,
maybe I'll see you this weekend and you live in North Carolina.
If you're fucking crazy enough to just travel there.
We have desk.
I have a desk squash show here Friday.
By the way,
tickets are on sale.
It was as calm,
calm.
It's a secret.
You've got to say who's on the show.
It's a secret right now.
You know it's going to be quality because it's death squad.
I'm trying.
I'm board.
You don't know who's on a,
actually,
I know a couple other people.
I'm still waiting on a couple of people,
but sky TBD.
Hilarious.
You are going to be on it,
Huh?
You're going to be on it.
All right.
I'm going to be on it.
Randy Lik he's going to be in it and it's really hilarious.
Comic named Al Jackson.
That was on a few of a Ra shift fears,
uh,
podcasts.
I just met him last night and it seems really funny.
So we're going to have him.
Do you want to listen to our spirits podcast is called the skeptic tank.
You can get that shit on iTunes.
Joey Diaz is the Church of what's happening now.
You can get that on iTunes as well.
Tom Segura,
our boy and his wife Christina Palicki,
the very funny and beautiful purse.
Christina Palicki,
you can get them a,
their podcast is called your mom's house.
That is also available on iTunes.
All this shit is free.
And of course the Duncan Trussell family hour,
that is the death squad universe,
ladies and gentlemen,
and we'll see you guys soon.
We love you all.
We feel it.
We're moving in this thing together.
Somehow or another we will make it all better or not or it doesn't matter.
It goes on forever.
It's repeats itself.
It's been fucking see on the next cycle,
brother,
they kiss.